Hello everybody!
Whoa!
Sorry, let me pause this video.
Curious.
I downloaded the trailer.
Um, hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god.
Feels, I feel so relaxed right now.
It's been a while.
I hope you guys are okay with the low supply of vitamin
doki.
Oh, um, it was sort of like an unplanned rest week, because
I did say I was like, ah, I'm gonna take like three days
off.
I was and I ended up like I just disappeared And then and
then and then twitch was like oh donkeys having a rest week
time to invite her to twitch rivals And then I got invited
to the fortnight twitch rivals and and then that stuff shit
happened Oh my god definitely said yes to it was so fucking
sweaty like why am I there To be fair at least like I wasn't
last like That's all that matters.
I wasn't last.
But yes, I feel like super relaxed right now.
I don't remember how to stream at the moment.
I'm at this, you know, like when you haven't done something
in a while, so then you're just...
I know, like, Doki, you were there yesterday at Eva.
What do you...
Okay, but that's different.
I have, like, four other people to talk for me.
And then, so, I had four other people to talk for me, so it
wasn't, like, actually streaming.
with the boys, like hanging out with the homies.
For those who don't know, because for those who don't follow
me on Twitter, I really apologize that the YouTube people
who don't follow me on Twitter and being like, what do you
mean you were doing a watch party of Evo?
So on Twitter, that's why you gotta create a Twitter account
just to follow me.
But I showed up at the I guess it's sort of official watch
party.
One of the official watch parties for evo which was uh team
brawl pro uh so a lot of people thought i was gonna show up
because it only showed like all the other members in team
brawl pro so brawl pro god brawl pro your name is so hard to
pronounce sometimes when i'm talking like like a moderately
fast speedy but um i'm afraid of twitter that's why you only
follow me because all i do is just retweet r retweet merch
uh retweet some fans to interaction and also tweet my
streams like and sponsors that's why you only follow me
because there's nothing else but just dokey stuff uh anyway
um so um it was like sort of like a surprise guest
appearance because i didn't think i was gonna be there as
well um but then like i i messaged like uh the day before
because i saw you know everybody was like taking pictures
hanging out and everything um why did i not announce that
wasn't going to evo because i didn't want to like you know i
wanted to like sort of separate i didn't want people to sort
of like know where i was type deal so that's why like i
didn't say because i know a lot of people are like are you
gonna be at evo are you gonna be evil if i say yes people
will try to find me if i say no um then like that gives a
precedence of like whether or not i'm gonna show up
somewhere like you know i'm willing to say where i'm gonna
show up because i don't want i don't really like people to
like approach me out of nowhere because i'm an introvert so
i feel pretty awkward about that type of situation so that's
why i didn't say whether or not i was going to be there or
not so like if like you know if i'm going to be somewhere i
wouldn't announce it i wouldn't say it like um um that's why
i never i never i never like i don't want to like set
precedence of whether or not like i'll be like no i won't be
there and so then people assume that would tell people where
i'm gonna be next time um so like that's why i was like oh
people would be like are you gonna be there and i'm like i
can't say yes or no like that's literally what i meant i
can't confirm or deny but i didn't want to like you know be
like i wasn't gonna be there um but it was because i had a
really i needed a break and um i needed to like there was a
lot of stuff going on as well so sadly I wasn't there uh I
wasn't there physically at evo so but I did like uh I did
like that doesn't mean like uh say jam was really nice about
it and said like if I ever want to go anywhere like they can
use that money to fund the thing for me next time um because
I said unfortunately I can't make it to this year's evo and
stuff like that um so uh say jam was incredibly nice about
it and he was like oh don't worry you ever want to try to go
to any evos in three fucking evos yesterday they wrote sage
i was like we will help fund you for that and um uh like the
same prize the same prize as the like winning sage i'm slam
type deal so i really appreciate it he's such a nice guy um
in general um but anyway yes i was at the i guess like it
wasn't a fish it was an official wash body but it was hosted
on team of brawl pro like mr brawl
coney slime matt and uh brawl pro we were all there just
hanging out um just watching i was just gonna be there for
techin um but uh but then like you know it was like street
fighter was like the finals like the last match i had no
idea what was going on um but street fighter was like the
last like the last tournament before evo ends and i was like
you know what i'll stay as well So, that's great.
That's great time watching.
I remember, like, I haven't watched Evil in a long-ass time.
Like, I've seen, like, best of moments where, you know, the
celebrations and stuff like that, like, people celebrating.
I've seen stuff, clips of that, like, of, like, the endings
of, evil events, like, evil tournaments and stuff.
But I never, like, really...
I haven't watched an actual, like, the tournaments in Evil
in a long-ass time.
So, it was great experiencing that again.
and uh and i had a great time i had a great time with the
boys and we took a picture and everything matt was really
nice because i asked matt if he could like help me take a
picture with everybody and then like i called in on uh lazy
matt man's phone and then like uh put the camera on and
that's how we got the photo together and then we all got
together and had the photo i was really happy about that
because um originally originally it was just to take a photo
um with i just with a team because I saw everybody was
having such a fun time together on Twitter.
So I messaged Matt and Brawl Pro.
I messaged Brawl Pro if I could take a photo with a team
before everything ends.
And then he was like, yeah, yeah, of course.
Of course, we like, of course we want to.
And then so that turned into like, wait, can I actually show
up at the watch party?
And then they literally got me into the watch party the day
before, like, um i think like i asked the day before and
then they got everything ready to set up like this the
morning of uh the watch party so in the morning um they're
like they messaged me and they added me into this big group
chat with the evo team like the evo technical team um like
the people were running like evo and stuff so they they set
the production team of evo in a group chat with me and um
and then like in the morning of i had to do like a tech
rehearsal uh because they have really added a YouTuber, you
know, on the broadcast before, I think.
I think, am I, I don't know, sure.
I might be like spinning words on my ass right now, but but
like the production team didn't really never really done it
before.
So we were doing like a technical test and everything.
And like 11 in the morning.
And then after that, like I came in at like, you know, at
like 3 p.m.
and stuff to get ready for the watch party.
But it was a great time.
I had a great time.
And it was a great experience.
I really love Team Brawl Pro.
Honestly, I think it's like one of the best experiences I've
had as a YouTuber in a tournament setting.
And it was great meeting them.
And I'm really happy that I was able to do a watch party
with them.
Anyway, on other news, I need to tell you guys the story.
But during my rest week, I had to do like, another technical
test for um um acghk for one of the conventions i'm doing
and in one of the conventions we're doing we're uh i'll be
playing apex with some fans um during acghk and it was so
funny because i had to do a technical test and um they
wanted me to play a game of apex uh to check the sound and
everything and so so you know it was me the the production
team for the convention and the call and my events manager
so you know we were they were all listening into the
gameplay and while i was playing in the middle of this game
the lifeline player in my team was like yo dokey you want to
you want to he was like yo dokey you want to like squad up
and then i'm just like everybody was you know we were on top
like we're all like trying to do the technical test and then
so like everybody heard that and then i was just like so
awkward and so then in the chat i was just like um like i
typed out um and then he was like the guy in the in the game
was like bro bro trust me i'm a fucking goaded lifeline and
then everybody just and then like it was like the protection
They were just laughing their ass off.
And I'm like, bro, this is so...
They were like, because I'm like...
I was like, can't tell.
I was like, bro, I'm doing a fucking technical test right
now.
He doesn't...
He doesn't know.
Like, the stab was, like, just laughing at him.
And I'm like, oh, he doesn't know.
It was so funny.
I'm like, bro, bro, not the time right now, man.
he lacks the critical information um but anyway during my
rest week um it was just some random i just bumped into some
fucking random lifeline player um anyway so uh juno the
newest support just came out well the tech the testing of
juno just came out but me not being able to read didn't
realize that Juno was only available on Friday Saturday and
Sunday I thought Juno was gonna be there forever I didn't
realize it was just like a technical preview of her so I was
like super excited because I was like oh I'm gonna take a
rest this like you know I'm gonna take a rest and then I'll
I'll check her out after like rest week is over little do I
know today is the day that she actually was officially not
available about to play so I never got chance to check her
out I never read the details I was like Juno!
And I was like oh my god like that movie but also
Anyway Juno is pretty interesting because she's basically
every support combined together so a lot of people are
saying that she might make Lucio obsolete because she has a
speed boost um and her alt is a speed like alt so she has
like you know lucio's whole thing is speed boost so that's
like unfortunate for him um but everybody was saying that
she's really really fun to play i'm really sad i couldn't
check her out before she gets nerfed because you know in the
previews um i'm pretty sure she's gonna get like adjusted
and nerfed during before because she's coming out next
season she's coming out in august so i'm just really sad
because i really want to during like the actual um the
actual like gameplay time when like she's like fresh and um
hasn't been touched yet by devs or anything because the devs
are already saying that like oh we're gonna adjust her after
the technical preview so i'm a little bit sad i'm actually
i'm really sad because she must have she was gonna be the
strongest she ever was like during the technical test uh so
yeah But other than that, she has like DP, she's like, she
has Anna, Lucio, Mercy, and there was something else.
It was like, people were saying that she has like Anna,
Mercy, Lucio combined together.
So I thought that was incredibly interesting.
Because like, you know, and that she requires aim because
you have to shoot people to heal.
Which is always a great thing.
Like, skill, I'm so sorry for, like, if I insult anybody who
plays, like, the non-aiming characters.
But I like playing support characters that require actual
skill.
Because I find them just more fun.
Bro, Lucio is so hard to aim.
It's literally a projectile.
You cannot say that.
Lucio was like, okay, you clearly played with bought Lucio's
who don't move, who don't even wall ride.
Lucio rollouts.
Lucio projectiles.
Lucio's all about living to, you gotta live to keep your
team up.
You have good movement.
Anyway.
um as i was saying
as as i was saying um i would i feels like juno seems like
an incredibly fun character to play uh i asked one of my
friends like because like they tried out juno um during the
weekend because i was like oh i realized juno's not
available anymore what was juno like and then they were
telling me like oh yeah like um she's really fun to play and
that she has a lot abilities uh she has a lot of abilities
and like to keep track of so she's gonna have a very high
ceiling um skill ceiling which is great i like that i like
that some heroes have like high skill ceilings i still okay
like there's like a couple of heroes that i still have never
learned because i realized like when it came out i realized
that they were never gonna be meta in support It's the worst
thing Okay The biggest issue with a lot of newest Support
characters that they add in Other than like Kiriko Is that
they never become meta Like they never become like support
meta Other than Kiriko So like Lifeweaver Was like dog shit
Baptiste Like there were like other characters you could
play Ilari Seeing there Unless you're a DPS player that just
wants the DPS But then To have a good Alari, in order to
make Alari a good pick, you have to have a really good
support partner to help keep everybody up.
Because Alari is like half DPS, like majority DPS and then
support.
And then also like good like placement on the pylons.
Bab has been, no, he's not meta.
You can pick him.
You can pick him, but he's not like, he's not like meta
meta.
considered throwing.
Like, you can pick him, but you're not really throwing when
you're picking him, but there's, like, better supports to
play.
I feel like, because, like, I feel like, you know, other
than, instead of playing Bap, you could play Kiriko instead,
due to, like, Kiriko.
Like, if I had to choose between Baptiste and Kiriko, I
would pick Kiriko because it's, like, similar kit.
And then I usually play Ana because Ana has been, like,
fucking like uh I mean like the Kiriko's better because she
cleaned cleanses I honestly think Kiriko's like the better
because he she cleanses than bab's kit So that's why like if
I had to choose between the two.
I'll just play Kiriko um But Anna's always been like hard
meta for like a while now Um, and then I play zanyad.
Yeah, Anna's always like top three um bab is also mostly
like if your teammates are like w key and they just want to
die you pick bap just for the heels like is there any time
like if you have a rhyme player a rhyme main and i didn't
avoid the rhyme main um usually people will go bap because
like you know just to keep the fucking ryan alive so that's
why that's why people will go baptize but that's like
literally the only time i see people pick bap because
they're like all right Knight had once to fucking die so I
gotta pick Baptiste so like he doesn't do that like
um Daisy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I
lost a lot of faith in the hero design team since Overwatch
2 launch to be honest most of them have been crazy OP or
crazy underpower and a lot of not been that fun they give a
super chat thank you thank you apparently Juno is very
different from like a lot of the heroes that they released
um I like how like the day after this stream i'm playing
marvel rivals so we can have like fresh comparison between
the two um because like marvel rivals is technically going
to be like overwatch's competitor even though it is third
person um so like we get to like you know compare it
directly in between the two
um anyway uh i heard juno was incredibly fun to play and
also like you know it revitalized a you know i guess it's
like a win-win situation for everybody
if you know you know all right let's watch the trailer i
watched a little bit of the trailer um i heard she's like
she works with me like in the lore uh in the lore atmosphere
she works with she used to work with me um so i thought that
was really interesting but no one really pays attention to
the overwatch they fired the person who did the overwatch
lore so like i don't know what's anymore so they did they
fired the head guy who did the overwatch lore like um so i
don't i don't know what's going on anymore so i haven't been
paying much attention to the lore like in the beginning in
the beginning the lore was really interesting but i i felt
like the more it went on the more confusing it got so i i
don't know oh it got like super convoluted and like lots of
rec cons were happening so like i stopped paying attention
to it um no one really pays attention to the lore anyway
these days whoo all right so that's the spaceship where she
comes from
yay oh it's like a tracer gun i just noticed it i am
prepared to cause trouble i don't like the font I really, I
don't know, it feels like middle school PowerPoint project I
don't know the that's what the fun reminds me of Like like
it looks like fucking PowerPoint middle school PowerPoint
Like I was like my wife is so cute
Do you know what she reminds?
Oh, that's what she reminds me of the fucking idol girl in
Marvel rivals where she dances to heal Come on guys dance to
here.
Let's go.
That's what she because it's the gliding I wonder if it was
inspired by that Yeah, dazzler the clap That's why I was
like why is she so familiar you had the kpop girl in marble
rivals Because like she the way she moves is just like her
because like they both like glide Orbital ray That's asher
crazy.
She sends out a fucking ray from the sky Then she's like
literally Luna snow you're gonna see exactly what I mean.
That's why I scheduled Marvel well to be fair This is why I
scheduled Overwatch before Marvel rival so you can see the
direct comparison between the two cuz that she she even
looks like her Like it's like isn't that like okay to be
fair.
They both have like short hairstyle like it's so similar
It's so similar I Alright, so that is Juno.
Alright, let's check out I downloaded somebody's gameplay
too So we're gonna pretend I specifically looked for
Somebody who has like No commentary so we can like I'll
pretend I'm playing Okay, just for you guys.
I'm gonna But this is It's from this guy.
This guy has like, I think this video Has like zero views or
whatever.
Like Okay, sorry.
This video has two views And it's from me.
Um This guy This is it guys i'm playing i'm playing juno on
the the controller right now but um i thought i just wanted
to look at i just want to see what the gameplay is like so
you shoot to hear um but yeah who shout out to get that guy
literally like there was like three people with no
commentary juno gameplay two of that gameplay was like in i
think like i don't know what language it was in It was not
English.
Like, I think it was, like, a European language.
I don't know.
I just, it was...
It was not in English.
So I was like, I'm going to download an English gameplay.
I think she is projectile.
Oh, my gosh.
You can tell this is, like, fucking controller.
Like, move it.
Oh, okay.
So that heals everybody.
Okay.
That's nice to know.
Oh, and then she has a...
What is that?
What is that shield?
I can't tell what that shield is It's like you're shooting
Okay yeah the super soaker Yeah the controller turn Oh the
heels are really nice It's like super fast I don't know what
the Is it speed ring?
Oh it's a speed ring Okay so when you're in the ring you're
faster That's really nice So like That's pretty good I think
I like and then she like glides like Mercy apparently, like
her gliding.
Yeah, like I like how, like how, look how fast I, okay, look
at your Arissa!
Heal your Arissa!
Okay, this healing is insane though.
I think the healing is insane, the output.
For how fast it is.
I'm just like thinking like how fast would your heals be if
you were in the speed ring in general.
If you're all in the speed ring and you just, like if
you're, if you speed ring yourself, heal um it seems like it
could like save uh you can save somebody really fast from
that no heal only cp yeah her missiles oh yeah yeah yeah the
missile heal is locked in yeah i noticed that too um
such a fast heals holy shit in general and i like how it's
locked in so like you don't have to You can, like, do the
locked-in missile and then, like, hide behind the wall right
after.
Shoot the monkey!
Oh, okay, sorry, I can't.
Console players.
Just, I don't know.
Console players has, like, a different meta.
Because I know a lot of console players play Torbjörn
because they have, um, they have, like, the extra turret.
DPS only bats have no excuse now
It feels strong But I feel like they're going to nerf this
That's why I'm really sad I didn't play it during the
technical preview Because they're definitely going to Does
this heal at the No, does it?
Fly more This is the most round Fucking Juno I've ever seen
You can literally glide.
Oh!
This is the speed, right?
Wait, what?
Wait, it hits them too?
Wait, it heals and hits!
Wait, did you guys see that?
It heals, it heals and, like, hits people.
And DPS.
Wait, that's so good!
Wait, this fucking character's busted!
Okay!
Yeah, that's actually insane.
It heals and damages.
Because I saw the missiles hit, like, the enemy team.
Ults heals and damage boost.
It's good for...
Yeah, she seems like a...
That's what I'm seeing.
Like, Lucio's gonna be back in jail.
Back into baby jail, you go, Lucio.
Nobody who wants to...
Oh my god, that's counseling.
I wouldn't say busted giving the skill requirement.
Yeah, but in my Elo, she's gonna be busted.
Like, yeah, in my Elo, she's gonna be...
Like, all the DPS players are gonna try and play her.
Like, how all the DPS players play Lari.
Like...
And Ana.
Yeah, good Juno would be terrible to play against.
All right, I'm Junoing.
I'm Junoing right now.
All right, Orissa, go in.
Go in.
I need you to engage with that Winston.
Sorry, I'm trying to immerse you guys right at the moment.
Lucia provides a steady speed boost.
Lucia has always been like two.
super uh i think like juno might be more what's the word
juno's gonna be uh more versatile in like what you can you
do with her because lucio is very uh what's the word
situational he's very situational because right now only
people play lucio for like ryan or uh junker queen that's
like literally the only times I see Lucio being played.
But I feel like Juno works so much better.
It seems like for different tanks.
Lucio sucks.
Yeah, he's been in Lucio jail for a long time.
Usually only like Lucio one tricks play Lucio.
Or you have a Junker Queen.
At least that doesn't go through.
Yeah, fuck this Mercy Blair.
At least like...
Uh...
No, never mind.
I was going to say something good about Lucio, but he hasn't
been good in a long time.
Yeah, I feel like... I like how, like, Bubbles work.
Like, you can't heal through the Winston Bubba.
How would you rework Lucio?
It's really hard to rework something when there's so many
characters now.
I don't know how, I feel like, I don't know how League does
it, but, like, it's always so hard to balance, like,
characters, the more, because, like, you know, the more
supports you have, like, the more characters you have in
certain roles, the harder it is to balance them to work for
other, to make the other characters, like, work, because
it's, like, then you're going to make Lucio too strong that
he's going to be a must-pick, and you don't, you don't want
that.
You want to have people be a, like, counter-swap, because
that's why, the whole thing oh my god okay i fucking okay i
hate the new i really hate oh poor guy
i hate i really really hate the tanks in overwatch 2 now the
current i don't know like for those who haven't played in a
while this is the current meta when it comes to overwatch 2
for tank players and this is why nobody wants to play tank
it's all about which tank counter swaps last i have had
games because i've been playing this season because i want
to end top 500 this season i'm playing okay so i'm playing
overwatch and like literally it's all tanks are just counter
swapping each other non-stop it was oh that was the end okay
that's literally it it's always tank swap until someone goes
manga i don't like it's literally counter swap counter swap
counter swap counter swap manga
it's so annoying and then they would chit-talk each other
because whichever tank wins the counter-swap battle the the
winner of the counter-swap battle Would be like, fuck you
for counterswapping.
And I'm like, you're both counterswapping.
Like, what do you, what do you, you're both the problem?
Like,
like, what do you mean?
Like, ew, this always happens.
They would yell at each other for counterswapping.
And whoever wins, shit talks, the other tank.
And be like, a shit player keep counter swapping and i'm
like you're both doing it
be the change you want play no that's the thing that's what
tank is now i swear i don't know i don't know if we're going
to experience it today but this is literally what tanks are
now it's literally non-stop counter swapping until somebody
like until the last person who counter swaps at the end
which is it wins The last counter swapper usually wins
because they don't have enough, because the other tank does
not have enough time to counter swap to win the game.
Like, it's always that.
It's so annoying.
It's, anyway, we're going into rank.
We've seen a lot about Juno then.
It's awful.
It's so awful.
Like, I'm not, as the person that's playing the support
that's not on the tank roll, it's so awful because I can't
do anything about it.
It's basically whoever knows how to play Yeah, it's who
knows how to play the most tanks And like swaps the last
It's so bad Like It's like nobody plays tank Because it's
such a terrible experience Like I Watch experiencing it And
watching it as a support player Is a fucking terrible
experience I feel bad for the people playing it For the tank
players playing it uh it's not even it doesn't matter
they're broken like it just you know it's just terrible it
feels terrible because then you know you lose because you
don't know enough tanks you're not good enough at all the
tanks so you lose yeah he who swaps last usually i've not
warmed up by the way so I haven't played Overwatch.
I know I said, like, I wanted to, like, practice...
Um...
I wanted to practice Overwatch.
Uh, because I wanted to get...
Oh, my God.
Bro!
One...
Let me 1v1!
I'd have to literally fight a Doomfist!
Um...
I know I was just, like, I want to end Top 500 for Overwatch
this season.
But I haven't played Overwatch in a bit, like, since a week.
So...
What the...
Oh, my God.
Bro, I'm fucking streaming.
Let me have this.
Oh wait, I forgot to give you guys audio.
It's alright.
It's fucking deathmatch.
Who cares?
Uh... Alright, there we go.
It's literally deathmatch.
Who cares?
Alright, where's my lane?
See?
That's fucking right.
Reversal.
Bitch.
Oh, what the fuck?
That's not right!
Oh my god.
Come on, let me have this!
Stupid Reaper.
Okay, I hate that I miss when Cassie didn't have like fall
off So it feels good to shoot somebody.
Bro, that's fucked up No, I missed the shot that bad is bro.
That's fucked up Where are they they're up in the house?
Oh, well, where did they all go?
I don't want to be what?
Whoa, whoa Yeah, thank you.
Yay!
Bro, no!
Oh, it's okay.
I got...
Yay, I'm faced with my one kill!
The Plumacy wins again.
That's nice.
No, he's literally one.
Get your goddamn head.
Yeah, pick your head.
That's fucking right.
I thought so.
I fucking thought so.
Bro!
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
What the fuck?
What was I on?
What the fuck was I?
Oh, yeah.
I was, like, gliding a bit.
Arrow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Love you lots.
Overwatch sucks, but we still play it.
It's because, like, there's, like, literally no game right
now.
There's literally, like, nothing.
It's, like, either for us fucking, like, fast movement
shooters.
Well, I mean, not fast.
Like, moderate speed.
Because tactical shooters fast.
There's nothing we can...
There's nothing to play for us.
It's literally Overwatch or Apex.
Because then, like, Call of Duty is way too fast.
Like, I guess, like...
Time to explode, time to kill.
All we do...
Have you heard of Concord?
Yeah, I heard his dog shit.
Like, I don't know what you want me to say.
That's literally what I heard.
That's long, court.
Same.
And apparently, Kod sucks now, too.
Everything sucks.
We're just miserable.
we're just miserable players now fuck you I just want to
kill this one guy what the fuck that's fucked up that's
fucked up I saw you guys as friends miserable but addicted
we're miserable players we're just miserable there's nothing
else to do except for overwatch or apex because nothing we
we do like nothing we don't deserve joy that's fucking right
this is fucked up this is why did you come over here
this is fps is dying we have nothing left that's why marvel
if you like i don't know tps as well i don't really find too
much joy in tps but i like i I enjoy Marvel Rivals.
I think Marvel Rivals just scratches the itch for an
Overwatch player.
A lot of like ex-Overwatch players are playing Marvel Rivals
right now too.
The fucking goddamn Overwatch League um, ex-Overwatch League
players six stack.
Um, wait is this six stack?
It's a six stack right?
For Marvel Rivals?
Yeah.
The ex-Overwatch League players six stack that was top 10 or
top 20.
I swear.
If you guys saw Marvel Rivals leaderboards, um, for the
close alpha it was all it was all um overwatch players x
overwatch players or current overwatch players um all of
them were like x overwatch pros and uh and they just hogged
the top 20 because that's all they play instead of overwatch
yeah it scratches the itch for us it's like it's like
to uh watch skills transfer is over to marvel rivals even
though it's tps it's literally the same thing except
different pov uh blade thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you just realizing my stream site no it's just
where i'm in the death match which is like waiting for your
match to start lobby so even they were stream sniping they
were just streaming sniping my death match lobby so uh so
they also are suffering because they're queuing for rank
Because you have to queue for rank to get into those
lobbies.
So, like, we're all suffering because they're going to play
rank, too.
So, it's so real.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
Why do you play Farah?
Because then I have to go meta and fucking go.
No!
Okay, I'll do one life.
Because this fucker wants to play Farah.
I want to play fucking Zen.
It's fun.
Zen is fun.
Zaria, what are you doing, Zaria?
I think you got knocked off.
All right.
Well.
Oh, they're playing Sigma.
I wasn't going to play fucking Zignata anyway.
Dude, this Echo is farming the shit out of me.
All right, guys.
Time for some.
Time for some ZZZZs.
Time to play meta.
It's pharmacy time.
Yay.
Woo.
Pharmacy!
ZZZ!
Yay, Farah!
Get the fuck off, Farah!
Oh, I don't think this Farah knows I'm not there.
Goodbye.
Oh wait, I saved his life.
You're welcome.
Please, at least kill the sink.
Please.
Oh god, thank you.
Yeah, the thing is, this Echo does not have a Mercy Pocket,
so we win automatically because of it.
all right goodbye Farah you die you die if you die we you
die Farah no I'm not with you you don't have a pocket come
okay there you go we're fine it's all right this Farah plays
as if he's a heart has a pocket that's when you know Farah
yeah Farah can barely fly they they change something about
her so like Oh, God.
See, I took this fucking Fara, bro.
Literally one hit.
This fucking Fara.
No!
This Fara doesn't need...
Oh, well, somebody better tell this Fara.
Because this Fara's fucking playing as if he needs a pocket
right now.
Like, look at...
He's fucking playing like he needs a pocket.
Because he's so hyper-aggressive.
Like, no Anna's gonna be able to heal you like that.
You're playing out of LOS.
Winston, bro.
I don't know why he's playing Zarya, too.
This is the whole Overwatch experience.
Vera, please swap so I can play a better game, so I can
enjoy my game.
I...
Oops.
Time to leave.
What?
Okay.
Oh my god!
What is going on?
on!
Alright, goodbye Zarya.
I mean, I could, brus.
And then die for it, question mark.
No, no, I'm sorry.
You just gotta die.
Wait, unless... Okay, nice.
Okay, Zarya, I don't know, Zarya.
Like, Zarya, why are you there?
How did you get there?
How the fuck?
Somebody push the car!
Okay.
How did he get there?
Jesus.
For the greater good.
How the fuck did he get there, though?
Oh, no.
He went...
He had Sigma.
I'm gonna not be there.
Because he still has Sigma.
Oh.
Here it is.
Am I gonna get paused?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Where did he?
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know where he's Sigma ulted, by the way.
I...
I have no idea where the Sigma ult went.
Guys.
I just watched the Sigma fly for 20 years and then Echo
appeared?
Echo?
No.
God damn it.
It's fine.
Got it.
Let the Zara.
There we go.
Kill the Illari.
Kill Illari.
He's not healing.
He's just DPSing.
Alright, there we go.
I have no idea where the fuck I co-came from.
Oh, thank God.
Are you swapping?
Please.
Let me enjoy the game.
Also, I found Elk.
I don't know if you guys know this change.
I did not know this change because this was not in the old
overwatch rank system but you gotta win 50 games now in the
past you had to play you had to play 50 games oh my god oh
my god i heard it yeah you have to win 50 games which i
think is oh my god please leave me alone i thought that was
a change no wonder like jesus goodbye all right to defeat a
Rhine it's time to swap I swear to God swap Farab where I'm
not gonna pocket you anymore can we illari okay all right
all right let's go I I don't know why you wanted Lari,
but...
Wait, where?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It doesn't help that, like, you know...
Shit, I forgot.
That was not the pylon.
I wanted to use the pylon.
You can tell I have not played Lari because I never needed
to.
I never needed to play a lard.
Ooh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Ooh.
Alright.
I can't put the pylon.
No pylon, guys.
I don't know why you guys want me to play lard, but okay.
I'm trying to help him.
Oh my god, he's so low.
He's actually so low.
Wait, he's a lorry?
Why?
I guess for the alt?
I'll put it on the cart.
There we go.
Please!
Keep the Cassidy up!
Oh, what?
I'm behind the bar!
That's crazy!
Okay, I have ult though.
Oh!
Wee!
Nice.
It's fine.
We got the Hanzo up.
And then I can Ilarial at this.
I'll put it on here.
Nice.
Where is he?
Oh, fuck, okay.
I'll put it here.
Wait, what?
Yay!
I was gonna say, where the fuck do I use this?
They all dead.
They're all dead.
Yay, we're doing good!
That's all that matters.
All right, now I want to play Shin'yada.
Nice.
It's okay, I blocked the door.
I don't think anybody was going there, but I blocked the
door, guys.
All right.
Guys, I don't think anybody was there.
But, like, I blocked the possibility.
That's all that matters.
I heard they got rid of...
They're getting rid of gold guns, I heard.
Anyway, now that, like, I'm not corporate, I can say that,
like, people are planning on...
It's so fucked up.
But, like, it's like the Pink Mercy black market.
But, like, people are planning on buying gold guns.
Yeah, for, like...
because like we get legacy coins legacy competitive coins
and uh people are planning on like uh hoarding their legacy
competitive coins to buy like new character gold guns so
it's gonna be even rarer to find like gold guns for newer
characters so people are planning on like selling accounts
with like juno gold guns because it's gonna be really rare
to get it because like um not a lot of people save their
competitive coins because save them but like um because i
didn't have any character i wanted to are you fair again oh
my god was not paying attention as i was not paying
attention clearly oh they're running zarya i don't like that
okay i'm gonna put oh my god all right fine cool okay where
zarya needs to swap nice
oh my god I don't I hate I hate babying a DPS if I'm not
like duo with them because you don't have communication like
if they want it's so hard it's not hard but it's so annoying
to pocket somebody if you don't use comms for the pocket
just not as fun you know he's dead don't worry I got you I
got you!
Because obviously it's easier to pocket when you know...
When you know when they need it.
Yeah, you have to predict them.
Jesus, this is Echo.
This is fucking Echo.
I love the juggle of my orbs so much.
Oh.
They're just poking our Zarya.
Where the fuck is this Sombra?
I don't like it.
Oh, she almost has Zarya all that fast.
Holy shit.
You have orb.
I don't know what you want from me.
I need to pay attention.
So, like, right now.
Get over here.
There you go.
You're welcome.
I saved your life.
Oh, shit, fam.
I will pop all.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Get away.
That's right!
Get away from my ass!
I'll pick your ass!
Alright.
It's alright.
She's alive.
Supporting care.
My Ana's really good.
I really like my Ana.
Because she's landing her sleeps unlike me.
God.
The Sombra's looking for her alt.
I can tell.
It's just scary.
I can tell that...
Oh god.
I can tell that she's looking for Trat, like, a Sombra ult
right now, which is very scary because I don't...
No!
No way!
Oh god, I lived.
But it doesn't matter.
I lived, though.
He has all...
He has...
Sorry, please!
Zaya, please!
Please, I can't kick that away!
I can tell it actually hit me!
No!
I felt the song roll, too!
I was like, this is it.
Okay, I'm gonna go to Lucia, so we can...
We can still...
Oh my god, sorry.
My sense for Lucia was so high, and I was not used to it.
It's not used to...
Oh no.
Can we touch it?
Yes!
No!
They were so close to touching it!
I forgot I have a super high sense on Lucio because, like, I
haven't played Lucio in a long time.
Like...
I'm not playing...
I'm, like, not used to it at all.
I was like, whoa!
I'm not playing...
You tell I haven't played Lucio in a long time because this
high sense disoriented...
me so hard.
The high sense really disoriented me.
Oh no.
Farah!
No!
You got me good!
It's still winnable though.
We just need to reset.
We're super staggered.
I might have to use my res to like unstagger us.
Alright, time to babysit the Farah.
Hello Farah.
Your babysitter is here.
Oh my god, well...
Okay.
That was like on him, honestly.
Like, I don't know what that guy expected.
Like, honestly.
Oh, this is where I die, I think.
Here you go, Cassidy.
Like, I don't know.
I'm trying to figure it out too.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, he's actually...
Did I got solo ulti?
Like, what?
Holy shit!
I...
What the fuck?
I actually got this guy.
I was promised Juno's not even available.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking have to swap off, and then I guess
they really want me to play Lari.
Alright.
bro you were unfair what the fuck do you mean i was
literally okay
okay this is as defensive as i can get you literally went
fucking a w key so hard it's not our fault you w oh god
sorry please i just want to use this so we can resituate all
right we're gonna use this to resit to fucking resituate so
I can swap off please kill one person so it matters oh okay
I mean he wasted his ult so like that's good okay the
squashes Cassidy die in front of me guys I don't know guys
this is not the best idea right now all right
Okay.
Losing that Lucia that goes straight in.
All right.
This is where I die.
I touched it.
Your turn.
It's just why do we still have a Zarya?
Why?
This is what I mean.
It's just counter tank.
They went monkey.
It's free diva hours.
It's literally free diva.
Bro!
It's literally free diva pick!
It's literally the freest diva pick you can get!
Okay, you just get- guys.
Alright.
You're a great Zarya player, but you don't counterswap.
I can't.
I need a counterswap tank.
a tank that knows how to counter-swap.
That's really it.
She's good, but like, not against Winston.
Jesus, you're fine.
I don't care.
You die.
You still touch.
And you just didn't want to touch.
It's an easy target.
Oh my god.
He's a good Zarya player, but like, if we had a Winston
during the last defense, it would have been easier.
We literally needed, uh, we literally needed Diva for that
last part.
Oh my god, why?
Okay, I would have played...
Jesus Christ, juggling of orbs is so fucking difficult
sometimes.
Okay, well he's Ryan, so that's easier.
I know a lot of people are playing Alari though now.
Is our Ana okay?
Okay, as long as our Ana is okay.
Okay.
I'm juggling orbs right now!
Play fucking juggler!
Alright.
What the fuck is going on?
I'm amazed you got 13 devs.
Oh my god
Be fair both DPS has 13 devs.
So it's like I don't want to I think our heroes might die
unless we nice.
Okay, we did it But they literally have one fight.
So like I'm trying to make sure that yep, okay, never mind
Okay, they might push with that now All right of juggling
the orb juggling the orb right now oh god i can't i can get
damage in because of that stupid ride shield all right all
right backing up oh what nice let's get for us all right
nice i can trance this if needed there we go there we go
stay alive stay alive stay alive oh no all right we're fine
that's fine
there's somebody to my left they have shatter though like
100 percent and oh good luck they have shatter so like i'm
like a little scared about it oh nice oh but
okay please say larry no i couldn't live with the larry wait
is it anna i don't know it's me and on okay oh god oh god
sorry please please me me please please our pharaohs come in
me oh no i'm getting shot at by i'm getting shot at by larry
what do you mean
you don't ship i give you one free take kill
jesus christ What the fuck is going on?
Look here, girl.
I am.
Bro, there really these two.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
Die on cart.
Who made pro IGL?
Jesus.
This is how this is functional.
Bro, this is my first game.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
I know it was a good idea if they have...
I feel like Zen would be better picked just for the...
Just for the orbs.
But like...
More healing goes in.
This Ana is really good.
I like this Ana though.
This Ana has had really good...
Really good decision-making.
Quiet now.
Oh, shit.
Holy fuck.
Oh, that sniper.
Nice.
We're fine.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
I'm just going for the extra heals at this point.
Oh, my.
Oh my god.
People are so mad!
Oh.
I think the extra heals was a good decision.
Our ash is good too.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, we have a good ash.
I hope you have ice block!
Okay, you do.
Okay, nice.
Don't worry, Ana.
Got you.
I got you, Ana.
and I've got you too.
Okay, this Ash is actually carrying us.
There you go.
I don't want you to die.
You're not gonna die on me, Ash.
You're literally the carry.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got you.
I have all two.
I might not be DPSing, but you're all alive.
And that's all that matters right now in this game.
What?!
He died so fast.
Okay, we just...
We did not... Alright, Ana, we leave.
Ana, we leave.
We leave Ana.
Ana, Ana, Ana.
We can recontest this together.
We have ults to recontest this.
Oh my god, shut the fuck up!
Our ash was carrying!
Shut the fuck up!
We had a... We have a good ash!
Oh,
okay.
Oh, that was a bad move, but okay.
All right, sorry, it's you and me.
Sorry, I wish you did not take that, though.
Sorry, why did you take that, Zaria?
Why did you take the heal?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Sorry I should not have taken the heals.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I got nanos.
But okay.
Oh.
I need to make sure our fucking ash lives though.
At this rate.
We got pick.
I think?
Why?
I might be dead.
Yeah, I'm gonna heal me here Okay, I'm sorry, please Oh,
they have Zarya grab too.
Do we have all?
We do we have all for the last fight
I'm trying I'm literally sacrificing I sacrificed my life
for this so I hope they do something with it Oh my god,
please there's hilarious ones.
Ilarious ones!
Oh god, please.
Oh no, mate, just freeze in there.
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
Please.
I'm trying to kick you up as long as I can.
I've got you.
Please, I've literally tried so hard.
Oh, guys.
Please, I kept you guys up for so long.
Please.
Guys, I think my team fell apart.
I think my team fell apart.
My team was a mess.
I'm going to avoid both the DPS and I'm going to avoid these
two.
not be together oh my god these two this guy this yeah they
cannot be together our fucking ash was so fucking good too
oh my god these two are sorry i needed a fucking swap He
still played Zarya until the very end.
He was a great Zarya.
But like, holy, he should have swapped out.
Our Ana was insane.
Our Ana was really good.
And our Ana was really good.
And our Ash was so good.
It was really good too.
But these two.
These two were just.
They were not meant to be the good.
They were oil and water.
They did not deserve to play together.
Holy fuck.
Like, I don't know what else more Anna, Ash, and I could do.
We were literally trying so hard.
They were so...
They were so committed.
They were.
They were so fucking...
I just wish he wasn't on fucking Zarya the entire time.
Literally...
Literally did not need to play Zarya.
Oh, okay.
Did not...
If he swapped out Zarya, we would have won.
If he was Diva, we could have won.
That was such a diva victory.
I knew we had diva there for the last fight.
The last fight before, during the stall, we could have won
that.
Oh no, it's deathmatch, guys.
So, like, game practice.
Because I need it.
Oh my gosh.
That was intense, though.
Ooh, you might have stunned me, but it doesn't matter.
I better aim!
Yeah.
Because that counters Winston.
That would have been a good Diva pick.
Oh.
Okay.
I keep forgetting that stuns.
That doesn't do anything.
I miss the stun.
You can still shoot when you're Cassidy thrown.
Oh.
No, my two kills.
My fucking two-kill lead.
Oh.
Here's something to my side.
Unless it's just a...
Oh!
Fucking nerd.
Play more Tekken at the chance.
If it was another tournament.
Yeah.
I don't think I can play Tekken.
That's like a regular thing.
I don't think I can be like an SGC streamer in general.
Oh, hey.
There's that guy again.
Well, at least we know he'll play.
Zarya.
At least we know.
Let's see.
What is our other guy gonna play?
Oh, attack!
Oh, okay, I can play.
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since you're talking about TPS, what about Splatoon?
Splatoon is dead in the West.
The only games you're gonna get in Splatoon are people in
Japan.
No, he's a good Zarya.
He just didn't swap.
Like, he's not a bad player.
And also he was like, he and the DPS player were just
chit-talking each other.
Despite how much I love Splatoon, it's a dead game in the
West.
Nobody in the West really plays it.
And even then, it's like, the pro players in Splatoon are
like, they don't, uh...
They don't, like, even make enough money to survive.
Woo!
All right.
Yep, there he is.
There's Desire.
There he is.
Oh, Echo.
I hope you peek me.
I hope you peek me, Echo.
Nice.
Oh, I just realized we have a Rhyme.
We have a fucking Rhyme.
I just realized that.
All right, that is unlucky for us.
Because usually, I mean, the enemy team last game had a
Rhine swap, but like, usually, yeah, I'm not feeling
confident with the Rhine.
No, I might be dead.
Please don't let this guy kill me.
Please don't try.
Jesus, he's going to have grabs soon.
All he's doing is just farming Grav.
Where's he?
I'm gonna...
Please.
Do something.
With that Echo.
Did he do something with that?
That one, that one.
Alright.
That's at least one bubble gone.
He has Grav.
100%.
I can tell.
Oh god.
I'm so bad at Sneeps now.
No!
All right.
Oh my god, thanks so much when I'm playing Anna, I forgot!
Why are you still all right?
Please.
I wish you were not still all right.
I wish.
Please please pick me, please either of you.
Please don't pick the ball, pick me!
Why are you still alive?
He's still... he's dead.
I don't know why he went that way.
Okay, that's good.
Come on.
Where is Zarya?
Oh god, no!
Oh, well.
I'm not gonna use my ult there.
still holding grab all right oh thank god thank god thank
god all right we're gonna die to grab guys when watch us die
to grab watch this that's huge yeah that actually is huge
like i i i need you to take me that's actually huge for us i
need you guys to not be so far away from me i need to be
away from the zarya too
oh thank god thank god the zarya was super i was not looking
when i threw that all right time to be cart bitch please
don't die i'm cart bitch oh whoa okay oh okay
Please don't die, Zaya.
Oh, he missed.
Fuck, I thought he was going to go back.
I didn't think he would keep going forward.
After all of that, I don't know.
It felt like logical that he would go backwards.
I know, doesn't that feel logic?
Alright.
Try to do something.
Oh, you know, I thought they'd be closer, too.
I'm not.
This is not logical.
It's okay.
They wasted an ult.
All right, I'll die.
I thought they'd be pushing out.
I predict.
That was a bad prediction from me.
Because they did not do what I thought.
I had a bad prediction.
because I legitimately thought he was gonna, you know, move
up.
I thought he was gonna move back after getting hit, and then
I thought the enemy team was gonna push us.
Also, they're still holding grab for last fight.
So, I don't know.
I should have went Kiriko.
I'm gonna see if I can swap to Kiriko in time.
Oh, no, Farah, no, Farah, no.
Lary, Lary, Lary, Lary.
He's still...
Oh, what?
All right, goodbye.
It's fine, we got the cart.
Okay, I'm gonna go Kiriko for the fucking Zariograph.
He still has all?
How does he still have all?
I've been having bad predictions, though.
I don't know, they're not doing the things I think they're
doing.
Because you would assume, since we're so close to the point,
that they would push up.
Because they're five, but they didn't do it.
So, like, I don't know.
Like, I'm so confused.
I'm just...
I'm trying to use logic.
But there's no logic.
Fair one, fair one, excellent one.
There's no logic!
Are they gonna ult yet?
Oh, here!
Come on, Zarya!
This is so smart to do!
Oh, here?
Where are you?
Where are you gonna all?
I don't understand
Wait, still no all?
Oh god So no all by the way huge big I don't know There you
go I cleansed it.
Oh my god, there it is
Okay, it got nobody, but there it is though!
There it is!
Holy shit, there it is!
Go girl, give us nothing!
Oh my god!
This is a D1, the Masters 5 game.
You could have done it like 20 years ago.
I don't understand.
Now we know why they...
They had like 20 alts last game.
And like, I don't understand.
I don't understand anymore.
I don't...
With a huge grab into nothing.
Um...
I don't know if I should...
I feel like if they're gonna run Ana again, I'm gonna go
Kiriko.
This is like the only reason to go Kiriko.
also like i felt like uh i don't know i felt like these guys
are way too aggressive
there's too busy typing team chat bro okay avoiding that guy
was a good decision it was a it was a good idea and so
avoiding the sorry yeah i know oh my god that was at that's
so embarrassing that's so embarrassing for that sorry
literally literally held that all for fucking 700 fights my
predictions didn't work because they had no logic in their
way that in the way they play oh my god i mean you could
tell he was a one trick zarya like it was not rocket science
Don't worry!
Okay, maybe worry a little bit?
Maybe worry?
I need to keep the Ramatra alive though.
Yeah, I can't focus on our Lari because our Ramatra, our
tank is much more important.
Oh, I got a new reload though.
Just in case I have to use my DPS.
Oh, God.
Please tell me that hits.
Yeah!
Basketball!
Huge wall.
All right.
Can you kill him?
No, we could have killed him.
No, I'm so sorry, Laurie.
I shot that guy once.
And I think that caused it.
That one shot.
That one shot that got you low.
Sorry.
Sorry, buddy.
You know, fuck it.
I mean, I have alt right now.
Alright.
Oh!
Yeah, you did!
Whoa!
This is where we leave our team.
Goodbye, Mae.
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
With loose tank, we leave.
how we do things please are keep arguing with your team
again she has all though 100 i hope he targets me and i have
fucking like uh what's it called i have tp so and then the
team is not with me that's like the most optimal plan to get
rid of he should be close to he should be close to another
grab come on give us something zarya come on zarya kill him
whoa kill the zarya how is he still alive how the fuck okay
he has no energy but he definitely has grab
all right he definitely still has grab We do have Ramatra
alt so he could, like, absorb.
I need to make sure I'm not near.
They have grab blade.
I think they're going to use that as a combo.
Most likely.
I'm not wasting our sleep.
I'll be fine.
Oh, God.
They're pushing up.
They have nano blade.
There it is.
Goodbye.
There you go.
This is how you do it.
Oh, I don't have cleanse, though.
I don't have cleanse.
This is how we do it!
And that's how you place the point when they have nanoblade.
That's the strat.
That's the nanoblade strat.
Alright, I have...
I'm going to stay here just in case.
Damn, what a fucking...
play that's what i mean when you're kiriko and they have
nano blade you get away from your team hope the genji
fucking tries to blade you tp to the other side climb a wall
and then tp back
nice that's fucking right get over here lucio so just bait
him yeah also if you have if you have like suzu you have to
have your suzu i hate smurf's crew Where the fuck is Smurr
me?
Damn.
I'm Smurr.
You should know Smurr?
I have a fucking, what was it, gold account.
Bro, this guy is on fucking May.
His name is Smurr.
Yeah.
Alright, nice.
That's how you do it.
Thank God.
Yay!
Almost Master 4.
I think it's support.
board okay um it is currently uh what is it currently for
support it is masters two i mean that's doable i still need
to win 50 games i do not have 50 wins yet yay i don't really
need another need a reason to have another account honestly
uh i can just grind on this account
That's the thing.
You have to...
I just avoid...
I mostly avoid tank players now.
It's like when you have a bad tank, like it changes
everything.
Like you just lose.
Like...
And like they could be like the best tank in the world.
But if they only play one character, they are fucking dog
shit.
If they literally have...
If they can only play one tank, they're dog shit.
It doesn't matter.
if they're like the best tank at that tank in the world if
it's just one tank then there's no point because oh no not
skirmish please not skirmish i don't want being a skirmish
skirmish people just say hello to each other um oh and in
the moment i said that
hello i'm a hammond one trick you're part of the problem
incredible timing all right what the fuck is playing Ryan in
my death match oh my god this is worse the tomb was the
worst pick are you trying to hammer me that's fucking right
that's fucking
that's what you get oh this is my hero no no no no No!
No!
Oh my god!
I still died to him.
That's fucked up.
Please, please don't come after me.
Please, if I don't shoot you, if I don't shoot you, you
won't shoot me.
I just, I don't, I do not want to deal.
No!
Please!
What a roller coaster of emotions.
Oh, God.
Okay, one of the tanks is still there.
I swear to God.
I will bully the shit out of this Ryan player if he fucks
with me again.
Oh, my God.
Is he protecting the Cassidy?
What?
Okay, fuck this.
That is so fucked up.
Fuck this.
That is so...
Wait.
He act...
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna fuck this right he actually fucking blocked for
the blocked for the Cassidy this fucker this actual fucker
that's fucking yeah that's like Right
That's fuck I become the tank player I
Shit whoops
Bam I become the tank player That's fucking right He did
this to me he did this to me
he did this to me
oh that's not what i wanted but that's fine i wouldn't have
done this but i became the villain
i'm fucking cringe the cringe that's
right Becky remember what you did Becky oh wait is he gone
oh he's gone he's gone yeah that's right get back here
that's fucking right get Backhand!
No!
No, everybody's tank now!
I created a monster.
Not everybody's tank.
My bad.
I create a monster, guys.
There's so many...
I've ruined the lobby.
I've ruined this lobby.
I made everybody go tank.
They all deserve it.
the cycle continues I created a cycle alright I need to know
what tank they're playing okay
we're not gonna have enough heals if I don't put I was gonna
play Zignata but we're not gonna have enough heals when
everyone is cringed no one else will be true oh shit wait
Grandmaster tank all right we have a grandmaster tank now
all right nice what the fuck are you here that means he was
gm last season does it take longer to climb oh it should
because like um there's not enough grandmasters right now
yeah i'm streamer mode so my name is different every game i
only do that because i don't want to like i don't want
people to throw purposely so that's why
what i thought that would hit and your reload i'm just
surprised that didn't hit somebody no
what how did that not hit i'm surprised that didn't hit not
gonna lie i'm just throwing sleeps randomly that's not good
bro go god oh god I'm sorry, I'm sorry, Sigma.
Oh, please!
I'm getting juggled!
I'm getting juggled right now!
I'm a mess!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I need to practice my sleeps.
I have not been doing good sleeps.
Already?
He's dead.
Please, he's won.
He's literally won.
Please, Sombra, shoot him!
I need to practice my... Wait, where?
Where has our soldier been?
Not gonna lie.
Where is our soldier?
I've not seen our soldier this entire fight.
I feel like I haven't seen our soldier at all.
Alright, he's dead.
Alright, there you go.
They have junk rat tire.
100%.
Please!
Oh, okay, I'm swapping.
We need Kiriko.
Where has our soldier been doing?
I swear, I've not seen our soldier at all.
How's your grandmaster doing?
He's getting fucking bullied.
That's what's happening.
There's, like, so many fucking juggling aspects.
Like, they still have Tyre.
Did they buff Elari?
Oh, he's so low.
Did they buff her?
Because everybody's playing her right now.
Oh.
Goodbye.
We're here.
Don't worry, we can adjust.
Right?
Alright, Lari.
You can kill him, right?
Oh, that's why everybody's playing Lari.
Okay, that makes a lot more sense.
I was like, did she get buffed?
Truly a hurt people hurt people moment.
Not so deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is- that's a good question.
This is- our team is not playing together.
And- Oh, Farah, Junkrat combo.
Wait, is that actually meta?
I haven't- I haven't been playing for a week.
And they made Junkrat- Fuck, Junkrat, Farah meta?
Really?
They changed- literally I played a week ago.
And this was not meta.
Oh my god.
I did not realize so many things changed in one week.
Literally stop playing for a week and this happens.
This sucks.
You have to learn Illari.
This fucking sucks.
Alright.
Oh, both of our DPS is dead.
Go for a DPS is dead.
All right.
Okay, I don't... all right.
You know what?
We don't need...
We don't need our DPS.
Oh no.
Oh no, I... the one trap.
The one...
Fucking giant serious!
I'm so unlucky I didn't...
I didn't see it.
Are you serious?
I'm so unlucky.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he has all.
There's no way.
He farmed that fucking...
He has been hammering our hog this entire fight.
There's no way he does not have...
Oh, alright.
Guess I heal our DPS now too.
Nice.
All right, come up.
Up there, there's the up.
There's the up.
I'm fucking making sure I'm not with them.
There it is.
There he is.
How does that hit me?
How does that hit me still?
Oh, God.
I'm staying up here.
I'm in my safe zone.
I'm in my safe zone!
Get in there!
Keep stalling!
I'm in my safe zone!
Oh, hi!
He's on me, but it's okay!
Because we're still alive!
Like, we're still alive, that's okay.
Oh, what?
fucking hook though what a fucking hook Jesus Christ oh my
god please me and the hide the dream team I'm literally
doing so much what do you mean please clutch up I'm
surviving you're I can't believe they have tire they have
tire and they're so close what is our DPS doing that's the
better question I feel like our DPS is not existed it's just
a hog at me
oh my god bro he's one oh the headshot though did you guys
see the headshot bro is this the first fucking soldier on
I'm seeing today
They're doing their best Just me and the hog The hog and I
literally survived so much Oh my god Bro, our fucking and
Larry Has worked damage at the other DPS He's doing The work
just This isn't a daycare Giraffe, you're trying to lock in!
Why would a fucking giraffe- Oh, it's our- No, our Symmetra.
Jesus Christ.
Our soldier and our Symmetra have not existed.
I swear.
I've not seen them.
Oh my god.
I'm glad I picked Kiriko.
That Kiriko pick was actually...
No way!
No fucking way!
I can't believe it.
Oh, hog.
Me and the hog.
Back at it again.
Keep the hog alive.
This is the troll.
Keep hog alive.
Save the hog.
Save the world.
Literally it.
Save.
Actually getting hard carried by the hog right now.
Saved.
Oh, he's so close to dying too.
I almost killed him.
Don't worry, I got you!
I won't get trapped this time!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
Keep Taug alive!
Me and the high!
Dynamic duo!
I like his new kit.
I actually like the...
What was it?
The grid name.
Oh my god, he went hogged.
Oh, he went hog.
Oh, my God.
He's angry.
He's so angry.
Oh, he went Zenata.
Oh, my God.
This is hard hog counter.
He went Zenata.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, that was fun.
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god, that's so fucked up!
That's so fucked up!
No, no!
Oh, that is so fucked up!
I did do this because I got scared I was gonna get hooked!
I got scared!
Alright.
Okay, no hook.
No hook, we're fine.
They actually went full hog counter.
That's actually scary as hell.
That's fine.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's a little overkill, but I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with that.
That was a little overkill.
Be afraid.
The fucking Kiriko alt.
Oh, I thought that was the trap.
The Kiriko alt hog alt for that one guy.
The hog player.
That poor...
Oh my god, our soldier did it!
He gave us something!
He got...
He's not Junkrat at all.
He hasn't Junkrat altered at all once.
Oh my god.
He gave us something.
A win is a win.
I'm going to GG hog.
You carried.
I'm giving a compliment.
I know.
He's like, yep.
Oh, it's him.
He's so humble.
He knows.
That wasn't...
Yeah, that felt like an uphill battle.
It was me and the hog against the world.
That 100% felt like an uphill battle.
That's me.
No, no.
He deserved that.
Oh my god.
Our DPS literally was non-existent.
Our hog literally 1v4'd, everybody.
Non-stop.
It was crazy.
Literally 1v4'd.
Oh, this is a new lobby.
That's fucking right.
You try to widow me?
You try to tracer me?
The soldier sim was actually wild, though.
Oh, okay, I killed both of them, so they two-timed, and they
double-teamed.
That, you know, I deserve that.
I 100% deserve that.
I killed both of them individually, so they teamed up.
Is he on Diva?
Who hurt him?
Oh, I did not mean to...
I did not mean to right-click.
put all right widow nice try nice try tracer okay am i am i
1v5 is this a 1v5 like they all came after me how the was i
supposed to kill three people back to back to back with no
heals fucked up that was actually fucked up i'm gonna help
you just fuck this diva fuck this diva in particular
actually fuck this diva in particularly oh my bro yeah fuck
this diva particularly
yeah that's right get ready for i better
I almost have a better shape.
I almost...
It was close.
Now I'm getting away from this fucking Orissa.
Climb out the stairs, Orissa.
This...
But this...
Y'all friendly?
Bro, this is deathmatch.
Go to a skirmish.
Maybe one friendly matchup.
That's what skirmish...
Holy shit, how is he still chasing me?
Leave me!
I'm just gonna run!
There we go.
Leave me alone.
Ooh, that was a good shot.
Let me full heal.
That was a rip.
Yeah?
That's fucking right.
I think that there's no Zen here to kick me off.
that's why he chases you you chase me i run away it's simple
rules it's the law of the land yeah here's somebody here
here mora no heals for you is that diva in there with the
mora
that's fucked up no i forgot it doesn't cancel it I thought
I was being smart!
I thought I was being smart!
I was like, oh I gotta cancel it.
I'm gonna... It's him!
It's the tank abuser!
I just realized it's him again!
It's the motherfucking a tank abuser!
That made me into the monster I am!
Oh my god, I'm gonna Zarya.
Fuck this.
Bro.
I'm gonna be part of the problem.
I'm gonna be...
It's him!
It's him again!
Wait, part of the problem.
That's fucking right.
I have a better tracking than you bitch.
Ooh, you're scared now.
Oh, wait, that's not fair.
That's fucking right.
I'll go tracking.
Oh, he left.
Okay, this is fucked up, because I've tracked two Genjis
now.
That's fucking right.
Give me that energy.
Oh, okay.
He keeps abusing Tank in fucking deathmatch!
I had to teach him a lesson, but I couldn't find a diva!
He was right last time!
I literally bumped into him again!
Oh my gosh.
I'm sad.
I couldn't find a diva to teach her a lesson again.
Alright, where are you playing?
Venture.
That's an interesting pick.
I feel like I haven't seen Venture.
in a long time.
I don't want to learn Ilari right now.
I haven't actually played Alari in a while.
I didn't realize if I knew I'd ever want to fucking buff
Alari.
Is it a Symmetra?
Wait, who was on my team last game?
Was it him?
No.
Okay, I'm going to avoid this guy.
Thank you.
This guy did nothing.
This guy was actually useless.
Oh, Oh, oh, Lucio Junker.
That makes sense.
We have Lucio Junker.
Oh.
Oh, but we're taking so much damage.
We're taking so much damage.
Oh my god, he's also...
Wait, he's so low!
What do I have to play?
Okay, I should play back then if it's Lucio.
God damn it.
Alright, I didn't even realize we had junker.
Come on guys, maybe we shouldn't be in this cubby hole!
Maybe we shouldn't!
Yeah, why are you still?
Go right, go right, go right, go right.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Whoa, we did it!
We didn't have to go right, guys!
We didn't have to go right!
Guys, I will get the sleep.
Guys, the moment I hit a sleep, we celebrate.
The moment I hit one sleep, we celebrate.
No!
It's fine, we still win this.
Let's see it.
We fucking celebrate.
Guys, it's been a while.
I don't know why, but I'm not hitting sleeps today.
Guys, I used to be so good on sleeps.
Guys, it's okay.
I can do everything else.
Sleeps don't matter as much I say as sleep.
Matter so much.
Come on.
Guys, guys!
Guys!
That's fucked up.
That was so fucked up.
That would have hit.
That 100.
Guys, you know damn well that would have hit if he didn't
fucking face.
If he didn't face.
That was 100% a hit.
Oh, shit.
Wait, did we use B?
Oh, we did.
I should go BAP soon.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to live here for a sec.
Yay!
Okay.
Guys, I did it, guys!
I did it.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, here we go.
I have to go BAP because we're running Lucio, Junker.
It simply is the way.
If we weren't running Lucio, BAP, I would run somebody else.
What the fuck is going on?
I did not think I needed to use that
guys can we not be here can we go main guys yeah can we go
main can we go main can we go guys he doesn't want to guard
her tank doesn't want it though the tank doesn't want to
you're welcome
Oh my god, thank god I was
It's by the love of God Jeez, cool price Oh my god Oh my god
Why are we so insistent On the fucking why Oh god, I'm
debating I was like maybe they have Reaper alt though so I
don't know I don't feel oh guys guys back up guys back up
oh this is not good this is not good I don't have lamp for
it yep I didn't have lamp for that no why did you beat alien
I I thought the Reaper was gonna TP on to us!
I felt it!
Lucy, why didn't you ult earlier?
You could have ulted and saved us!
Oh my God, he could have ulted and saved us!
He does do it if it's behind the wall.
If I had the lamp behind the wall before he gets in.
It was better than nothing, you know?
Please, I don't...
We'll run here, go fuck this.
Oh, okay, he's on Hammond.
Thank God, okay.
Oh.
The only way to live that was the loosey old.
There's nothing else I could do.
I also put that here, put that there for also the Cassidy.
Tank, you know, you can come.
Oh, my God.
Is our tank the only one not in the voice chat?
Is that why?
Hello there.
Yep, the very save.
Alright, good luck, Cassidy.
We're trying to save your ass right now.
Like...
God, if he wasn't on...
If he wasn't on Lucia, I would run Zignata for this, Ryan.
Nice.
Oh, we got...
We got somebody.
I need to save this cleanse, though.
Nice, we got two!
Nice, we got...
Oh!
A legitimate thought.
Okay.
Literally the wrong one to...
Literally the wrong person to boot.
I don't know what that Lucio was trying to do.
But that was the wrong player in the boot.
That's for sure.
I don't think I can.
I'm just making sure that I don't get hit on the side.
Wait, what?
Oh, God.
Did that not hit?
No!
No.
You're okay.
You're so healthy.
Where the fuck is that Ryan?
You're so healthy, Lucio.
You're so healthy, too.
Catch my...
Catch my hues.
Just catch the hues.
Catch it!
Yeah!
They're really...
Catch the heels!
Alright, nice.
We're five.
That's all they need to do.
Never play Overwatch.
The great thing is I'm already a streamer, so I don't have
stable mental health.
I mean, okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Woo!
Alright, let's go.
He'll be fine.
Oh my god.
I am not fine.
I hope that was going to be fine, but I was definitely...
I don't know.
I saw that Lucio face-tanking alive.
Yay!
I'm a streamer.
We're not known to be mentally stable.
I would be surprised if there is a streamer in this world.
that has good mental health.
That doesn't exist when you stream.
It's like the curse.
Is he still, yeah, I fucking knew it.
I was like, I think he has us.
Like, I was like, I'm pretty sure.
What?
I clapped my hands!
I clapped it!
Oh, nice.
Nice, they don't have speed.
He doesn't have speed, go, go, go, go, go!
He has no speed!
What?!
Lucio, you fucking!
He Ajaxed twice!
That was...
He...
He fucking...
He's done it though!
He's done it!
Yeah, yeah!
That seems right.
Yeah, you should...
You should 100% go Zenyatta after that.
Yeah!
Yeah, after what I fucking You saw it, you fucking should go
Zenyatta.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
He's good.
He should.
He was not good.
I mean, I think that our Lucio was not a good Lucio player.
He wasted his ult twice.
I saw it.
too.
Oh, man, I didn't.
I thought I could.
I thought he was gonna Oh, no, I have to reload.
No, he didn't.
Oh, what?
Okay.
That is interesting.
Okay, that is very, I have to die.
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
I was so confused what the play was.
I was very confused what the play was for this team.
Yeah, that's a Jeez, that...
That is 100% ATGs.
We had a really bad Lucio.
We...
Okay.
We had a really bad support party.
Oh my god.
We lost...
Beat twice in this one game.
Play of the game.
Oh my god.
No, we don't deserve that.
Alright.
It's time to play the game of...
a void day okay where's my avoids all right okay who was
this guy again this guy oh this one was a dps that argued
with the zarya okay i rather avoid the shitty support player
that was a terrible support partner that was not a great
support partner at all i did i hit one sleep
I did I just had my support partner just wasted his Lucio
beat like two times during games that we needed Like during
last like he wasted Lucio beats during last fights twice And
that's why he gets the avoid
Asleep that meant nothing it's okay.
Asleep is asleep at least it wasn't an all I wasted an
ability He wasted an all it always always has more of a
precedence Maybe I should play on the practice.
Okay, that's just mean that I deserve that.
That was mean.
I deserve getting killed there.
Oh, okay, I fell down.
I slowed down.
What the fuck?
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up!
Okay, I'm gonna practice out on the sleeves.
That's right.
I'm gonna do it It's time to practice out in the sleeps
No, no, I'm fucking around it.
I'm fucking bullying this guy again I need to stop doing
that I hear them Okay, that should have hit That should have
hit I don't care what anybody said that sleep should have
100% hit That's fucking right, Genji.
I can aim on Anna.
I just can't sleep.
Oh, you're scared?
You're scared?
That's fucking right.
You should be.
You should be scared.
That's fucking right.
You're
That's fucking right!
I did sleep though.
I slept him.
Do I try that again?
Yeah?
Are you scared?
Oh, you're scared!
That's fucking right.
Don't do that.
Don't fucking try and push me again.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, one at a time!
What?
One at a time!
That's fucking bullshit.
I got two time there.
Bro, every time.
Get away.
Get away!
You're bad!
Oh.
No.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's fucking right!
Get out!
I might not hit sleeps, but I sure I'll hit everything else.
That's fucking right!
You can only alt yourself in deathmatch It's only in
deathmatch That was scary though That was very scary I
thought I was gonna die to the chaser Get shit on I might
not be able to hit sleeves But I hit everything else Damn it
Look, I had to fucking kill so many, look.
Like, I literally killed, like, three people in a row.
I don't know if I could get the fourth in.
I don't know.
Three hundred meters downrange.
You fired once.
All right.
Yay.
I love the streamer mode names.
Yeah, those Genji's so embarrassing for those Genji's.
Actually embarrassing.
My God.
Should go back to the training.
range all right tank wake up oh we have maga maga time all
right i've been encountering a tank that counter swaps yet
which is crazy literally all the other games i've had is
basically non-stop tank swapping so it's nice oh anna anna
you killed us you actually killed us anna You killed Anna,
you killed us.
I'm going Kiriko.
I mean, this...
Alright.
It's Kiriko time.
Anna actually fucked us up.
If I had cleanse, we would have lived.
But I sadly did not.
I'm running double hit scan.
Okay.
I don't know.
Double hit scan and against Doomfist.
There you go.
Wait, where's our tank?
Oh, our tank is on point.
Why is he on point?
Why is our tank not playing with us?
You're lucky I saved your...
Okay.
Guys, I think this is a team death.
I think our team's garbage.
Guys, we have a pretty bad tank, guys, I think.
Our tank's just W-King, so we're gonna have to follow him.
I think I... I think our tank is not good.
Please, I can't.
Please, I pick Sigma.
No!
What?
Who gave this tank everything?
How was this charge?
What is this charge?
Who gave him every fucking utility?
Who shot his punch?
No, it's because, like, the thing is, if you shoot his
block, I think he had max charge, right?
Because, like, it fucking gets so much damage.
Somebody shot his punch, because, like, if his punch is
almost maxed out, you can insta- Okay, I'm not...
Like, you can't do anything about it, basically.
He has all...
Me has all two.
All right, they're gonna mail now.
Okay.
I...
All right.
I mean, that's great.
I tried my best.
He punched me out!
I clapped!
I literally clapped!
I collapsed!
This demon fist is good.
This is like a doom fist whoever he is.
I saw it!
You guys saw it too!
What server am I?
Oh, I'm on East Coast.
That makes sense.
Okay.
I'm on East Coast servers.
That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, we backed him off for one fight.
That's all that matters.
all right this doom is scary though oh i have to use that i
was so scared i didn't want to die it's okay he'll be fine
nearly wasted anti they used doom all they still have mate
all um they still have blade okay all right that okay oh all
right let me just get bullied
okay all right oh our winston is still alive
oh easy moly-tide
whoo somebody is giving this doom fist max charge and it's
not me because i'm trying to keep everybody alive right now
somebody is giving that doom max charge who is it that doom
has so much charge for his punch true it might be the turret
actually you're right i think our the doom is just farming
our torb's turret that makes more sense
hard to shift right now it's like it's like i need to time
it better the ship is so fat like it's so like slow compared
to um before because i clapped and i still get punched which
is frustrating i think it sucks when you have to relearn
characters and timing and stuff especially like not playing
at the thing is i literally didn't play for a week and they
changed so much frustrating part it changed so much after a
week I didn't realize somebody I am keeping you up as long
as I can please keep surviving when you play like support a
lot especially like the characters that are like meta and
they changed one thing like even like a something small like
seconds like it affects a lot because you have like inner
timing like reflex timing so for me i have like reflex
timing for like certain abilities so if it like throws me
off so much when it's they change one thing because i'm not
used to it all right i'm trying to keep you up right now oh
that that guy has so much charge Please somebody touch it.
I can't touch it.
I'm trying to keep you up right now.
Woo.
Goodbye.
Please.
I'm literally running around.
Oh my god.
My internal timing.
Yeah, I have to like manually adjust myself.
Because I can't, uh, figure...
I can't, like, use, like, internal reflex.
Oh, God.
Get me away.
Get me away from that doom.
I feel like if I let that doom touch me just once, it's
over.
It is actually...
Oh, God.
Goodbye!
Oh, please.
What the fuck?
do this ptsd get away from me get away from me
well i even do that now they don't have an honor oh nice
nice oh god i see the doom i i i thought he was gonna punch
me I reflexively um who punched him oh shit oh god that's
not fair you had the doom okay they used Reaper alt they
used doom alt so that's good that means did it Kiriko alt I
didn't The only thing they're missing is Nano.
Oh my god, everybody.
Everybody always come after me.
Why not the Mora?
The Mora has less...
The Mora has less movement than me.
She looks so juicy and vulnerable.
Oh god.
There we go.
It's him.
him it's him guys it's him i'm going to point guys hello
yeah i know i see you there yeah i know yeah i went that
he's getting a touch point most likely yeah he missed the
two missed get the mora Me!
I literally can clap my way away!
Mora just has fade!
I'm literally getting hard targeted.
It's actually crazy.
Every time I show up, the Doom tries to punch me.
Yeah, but the Mora!
The Mora's with me!
She has less movement!
Please!
Every time I clap, it's to clap away from the Doom!
Doom!
This Doom.
This Doom really wants to kill me.
It's actually crazy.
Our tracer's really good.
I would admit that.
Our tracer has been like getting non-stop picks.
Like he might have the lowest damage, but he's getting the
picks for that.
Which makes sense.
Oh, thank god.
Leave me alone.
Oh, he has max.
Oh, please.
I leave.
There's no point.
He's dead.
He's dead, Mora.
You should have left earlier.
I should have went with this, Aria.
I want to save.
Oh, Rissa.
All right.
See?
Oh, it's going.
The counterswap, but only on our end.
Because the Doom is just better than our counterswap tank.
No,
I saw him.
I saw him get so much fucking punch charge.
Why?
Oh, no.
I hear him.
All right But this this is winnable This is so winnable Just
get on point
This is so winnable I swear the guy No Guys, I don't think
it's winnable anymore
guys I don't know I don't know anymore guys I guys I think I
think we're gonna lose this game guys I don't know oh please
don't anti-aura sub please don't I don't have he has Reaper
ult he has Reaper ult I feel it I feel it oh guys guys
please live oh it's okay it is not okay it is not okay right
now it is it is not okay i don't feel okay guys i don't i
don't feel please arissa's doing so much guys He's gonna
die!
Mora, why didn't you like sit still for so long?
Help our team!
Go Mora, please!
Where is he?
Oh my god, we did it.
For another fight, we lived.
We lived along.
For another fight.
Please.
God.
Oh, please.
I need a... I have the solo contest.
Oh, my God, please.
That's so scary.
I don't want a solo contest.
Oh god.
Please.
I don't want to solo contest.
I beg you.
God, they got the point though.
They got the point.
Oh my, the amount of solo contesting I have to do there.
Go go go go go go!
Nice!
Please kill the carry!
Oh, he killed the carry!
Oh, the amount of dodging I have to do is curicle.
Bro!
Jesus.
Oh my god, it's so fresh.
I just jump around so much.
Oh my god, I can't- I can't- I believe I lived that long on
point.
Oh my god.
This Doom deserved the win.
We did not deserve...
This Doom literally was hard-carrying.
Holy shit.
That was so scary.
That Doom must be so mad.
He literally carried his entire team on his backs.
We did not deserve that win.
That Doom does...
That Doom did so much.
Oh my god.
Oh, this must be so frustrating.
I feel so bad.
I feel so bad for that Doom.
He actually did so much for his team.
I was climbing walls.
I was dodging.
I was weaving.
I was suzuing.
I had to...
He made me...
He made me fucking...
I was everywhere.
I was...
I was fucking everywhere because of him.
Jesus that was actually so oh wait no no that was so
difficult to play oh my god another one that's fucking right
okay I deserve that this way yeah I actually have to like
try so hard there I actually have to like think You can tell
the difference when you- it starts getting like higher elo
games.
Like the- my fucking decision making and movement!
But I have to like- you can tell when I start thinking and
actually play the game compared to like before.
There you go.
Get over here.
I should be playing Anna to practice sleep, yeah.
I can think.
I know.
Thank you.
That's not fair.
That's fucking right.
You got a free med kit?
I still beat your ass.
No!
The last brain cells.
My last brain cell fucking working on overtime there.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Oh shit.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Thanks, Ana.
I hear the Ana.
Oh, never mind.
She's dead.
Oh, dokey brain expansion.
But you can tell I'm playing Overwatch more regularly.
Because I'm actually... Oh!
Shit, you deserve it!
You fucking deserve that!
Fucking... Whoa!
You deserve that!
Versus whenever I play after, like...
very like a month i fucking not the manga manga get away get
away get away get away i will fucking run away run away run
away from the manga run away where did i go i will where did
i go
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god, the Ana beat him.
Oh my god.
I had to run away.
I was so scared.
Oh, connecting.
Come on, give me a game.
Give me a game already.
That's slippery, Cassidy.
That's me.
I see tank.
I run.
That's how it goes.
Oh, somebody's not This lobby's bug Are you serious?
Oh, okay, never mind That was a bug lobby
Alright I play Anna Oh, fuck We have Ryan I still play Anna
Oh Is it the awful symmetrical in the enemy?
Oh, it is!
It's Giraffe Boy!
I still play Anna.
Alright, let's go.
People don't really talk anymore in Overwatch.
They just play.
Guys, you want to see my sprays?
Want to see my animated sprays?
I'm a legacy.
Look at that.
It's moving.
And then I have this one.
And it will.
Wow, it's moving.
And then I have this one.
And I have this one.
And then it only lets you show four.
I'm an OG.
It moves.
Yeah, it moves.
Are you printed again?
Oh, balconies?
What do you mean?
shoot the balcony you're supposed to shoot the balcony so i
know so i can shoot through it it's the law the land it's
hollywood oh my god please no he ate my he's eating my
school thank god he was eating my fucking heels and
everything we can't counter the high ground we're trying Oh,
you're behind us!
Oh,
God.
Oh, we lost Cassie.
Cassie, why did you go up?
No, you ain't right!
Oh, my God.
I slept.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
I don't know what's
going on.
Oh, God, please.
Please come over to Wally!
What's going on?
Oh, I needed the rally near me.
I want a trip.
No, right.
I needed the rally on me.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God.
At least we have Diva.
That was hell.
I'm not playing fucking...
Okay.
Okay, so you go in.
Now.
Live!
Oh, this is not where I live.
This is where I die.
I'm not playing Anna!
Oh my gosh, that is not an Anna match.
Holy shit.
He fucking ate everything.
There was no way I could play Anna there.
The guy fucking ate all my shit.
Thank you, brother.
I just don't think we should have Kiriko.
I don't know.
I think we definitely maybe needed something that's not
Kiriko.
I'm not Kiriko.
Bridge, Brigitte.
Sorry, I was talking about Brigitte.
I'm not talking about me.
Oh!
Leave me alone.
Please.
He has Eva Bob.
oh thank god oh thank god i lived i was not sure i was not
sure if i was gonna live that
nice we're doing great i'm gonna stay on the ground i know i
shouldn't be but like i'm gonna stay on all right live i
don't have cleanse but live eat the meat if you can
i need you internet oh my god how are you so low how are you
so low oh i have cleansed i've cleansed i've cleansed i've
cleansed that's fucking right but you didn't get cleansed
oh he's so low though that's unfair this is actually a sim
map for him i think he's a sim one trick i just noticed i
think that would make sense actually oh god nice oh that's
very unlucky for you but we have i think we have what he got
fucking cleansed
please please live please live please i can't there's too
many things going on maybe oh i was gonna say pharaoh for
the Symmetra.
Because they don't really have any DPS.
Alright, I'm gonna stay here.
I'm gonna stay here so I can swap.
There we go.
I have to go Curacle for the cleanse.
We need to break the swap off.
Yeah.
Give me Zarya?
Zarya would be good on this counter for the counter swap.
This is a good Diva player, too.
I literally saved your life.
I predicted you to go that way.
Get predicted.
Oh, there's a Cassidy behind us.
This is bad.
No, I don't have cleanse.
I don't have cleanse.
Please stay alive for a little longer.
Please.
Please stay alive.
I'm sorry.
Our freak is not with us.
I'm trying so hard to keep you alive.
I think I I think we have a brig one trick not use my
cleanse let me judge you
you don't even okay I don't give up I wonder what the issue
is I don't know brig we don't need brig
Yo, you don't play Bragg!
What the...
What is your account?
What is your fucking account?
You don't even play Bragg!
It's
not Bragg!
Oh, okay, nine hours.
Okay, he's your least played support!
He's literally your least...
Let's play the support!
Don't understand!
Let's play!
This is a vertical map!
The reason why I don't think Brig works here is because this
map is vertical.
Like, this is a vertical map.
You're not gonna be useful as Brig with verticality.
Let him have fun.
He can't.
This game is now free to play.
He spent zero dollars.
Except for that brick skin, maybe.
Maybe the brick skin he spent money on, but like They can
use the skin where like I spent $40 to play whatever I want.
Oh now you play Lari.
Okay He wants to play fun.
Yeah, play and ring He is smart Bro, I avoided this fucking
Symmetra and now the Symmetra's gonna farm me!
This is not fair.
My avoid slots is to be used to gain as hard, not fucking
lose.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't peek, guys.
Don't peek.
Jesus.
I wish I was Juno right now.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so low, I have to heal though.
That sucks.
This is a really good Diva player, though.
I have to admit, the Diva player is really good.
Oh my god, I almost have UL.
Oh no.
We're trying so hard to keep you alive.
We're trying so hard.
I'm almost close to UL.
Can we play Fera?
Can somebody play Fara?
I think if we had Fara, it would work.
That's just me.
That's just...
Literally the only issue would be Diva, but if you have a
pocket mercy, you'll be fine.
Or Zarya.
Wait, why are we playing Zarya, though?
Maybe Zarya would be good.
Oh my god.
Bro, that diva died literally once.
Bro, Sigma, please.
Do not let the diva get mech back.
Please.
That's all I want.
There you go.
Go.
Go, go, go, go.
Alright.
I'm dead, I guess.
I guess.
They use four alts.
I don't know.
this team is yeah I don't know I don't know I don't know man
can we can we can we get Zaria in where the fuck is our
Zaria wait did we use a Lario I don't know maybe maybe a
Zaria would be a good idea guys what the fuck Oh my god, do
we do it?
Guys, it's okay, I got the turret guys.
It's okay.
It's okay, you're...
Oh my god.
I thought he was closer.
I actually thought he was closer.
Oh, this is where I die.
Goodbye.
Thank god.
I don't know who to avoid.
My entire team.
team is the best who the fuck do i have boy interesting i
you play every tank but zarya how is that possible it's just
tracking zarya is one of the easiest tanks to play not tank
players play zarya because he's she's literally the easiest
tank to play it's all about tracking and bubble management
can you not track it's just aim
people who don't know how to play tank they play zarya
how have you played it 30 plus seasons of overwatch just a
struggle
oh my god but tracking is hard we're in master elo how you
should not not know how to track by Master Elo time.
No, fuck this guy.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I think I'm just gonna avoid the tank.
I'm gonna avoid the tank.
All right.
You know what?
I'll get that Zarya player back.
Just because he can't play anything.
He can't play Zarya.
I don't understand.
Literally, you go Zarya.
Attack.
The only verticality is that one place.
He went Ryan this has to be oh my god has to be one of those
tank players that can't aim He literally went like Ryan and
Winston.
I mean Sigma requires he went every tank in the world but
Zarya
How do you play every tank we have but Zarya He played Diva
sorry I I'm back to
suffer once again it's just it's just tanks I lose because
of shit tanks like Alan Kaz duck Miki Medi and Neppers thank
you for the super chat thank you I didn't lose because of
garbage tanks and that's it if I have a good a tank i would
i can like i can like just keep him up and then we win sorry
i couldn't pee the toxicity out i tried i tried so high
oh that's fucked up that's fucked up gangu i'm nearly 11 hp
oh shit
i can always blame tanks you lose because bad tanks is
nothing else a good tank can actually 1v4 we saw that we saw
our hog 1v4 it's true we literally saw it in our game
then play tanks surely you can do i'm not a tank main
that's the thing i'm not a tank main but they are wait did i
get killed am i red no i'm shimada an actual widow player
i'm scared this is a natural widow player
i just waited for him to go across my crosshair because i
know he was around
don't aim i just wait for him to go i went for him the
fucking strafe into my crosshair that's all have to do if
they fucking do that shitty shrink shit yeah I just let him
walk into my my dot
okay no what you're not part of this widow fight yeah are
you serious
Come on, Cassidy.
Come on.
Oh, he's over there now.
Okay.
Oh, they're all so far.
There's a Lucio?
Is this Sombra?
Oh, no.
Is he gonna recall?
Oh my god, he recalled there.
I was not expecting him to recall there.
Fucking nerds.
Alright, where are they?
Oh, are they like chilling?
You found my present.
Where are they?
Are they...
I want to chill.
Wait, what?
I want to chill up there.
No fighting on this friendship rock.
Oh man, I wish I was in Lari.
He's not in the Friendship Rock.
You're not in the Friendship...
What?!
He's not in the Friendship Rock!
You said only Friendship Rock!
This is peaceful!
He didn't say I can't shoot on the Friendship Rock, just
that I can't kill people on this one.
Those are fair game.
They're not on the Friendship Rock.
Rock.
Where are they?
Over there.
Is that all of them?
That's all of them.
Oh shit.
Let's kill.
Come on.
Pick me.
No!
I was gonna shoot him.
What?
Why put me out?
He wasn't on it!
Nah, I don't want a friendship rock.
Okay, Diamond 1 to Master 5.
We'll see.
I don't know when to stop.
I'm having a good time.
Not gonna lie.
Uh, Mercy.
Should I play Lari?
One game.
God, I wish it was attack.
I'm not good at Lari, but...
Okay, I'll do one life.
I'm not very good at Lari because I don't play her often I
love how like I like the melee on this boom boom I'm glad
that Overwatch is doing fun skins now even though I would
never spend money
I don't care as much the range on these pylons are insane
Blizzard main in each category I play every support but okay
not every the supports I to say what supports i don't play i
don't play illari but i'm gonna see if i can because
apparently larry's meta now um i don't play illari uh bath
um life weaver i think those are the only supports i don't
play i know there's any other i just know like pylon is
crazy now the range
okay i just want to make sure i have like
See, there's the fact that...
The fact that, like...
Oh!
No, no, not my pylon.
Not my pylon!
Alright, I need to remember that shift is to bounce apart,
bounce away.
I'm gonna put the... I think I'm gonna put the pylon here.
It's the safest.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Fuck was he doing?!
Did you guys see that?
Oh my god, I'm fucking dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, guys.
What the fuck was I- What?
Was he stuck?
What the fuck was I Sigma doing?
He was- Okay, he literally threw that.
We actually had such a good play there.
He actually threw that.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I was like, what the fuck?
That was so winnable.
See, I'll put it here.
It's okay, he's on my pylon.
So he's too busy looking.
Oh no.
Oh no, are you serious?
Okay, we got Zarya though.
Oh.
I can't do anything about that.
Best I can do.
Just, like, head up.
Oh!
I'm going all in and I'll swap off.
I don't think, like, Elari's working for me.
For this team.
I'm not doing enough DPS to justify it.
I'll do it, too.
What?
Holy shit!
Did Elari got me?
Oh, no, the soldier hit me.
Alright.
I'll go out.
because they I don't think they're using cleanse they're not
using grenade often so
I'm not good enough as as uh Elari the player oh god oh god
I know my limits I know my limits when it came to Elari oh I
should go Curico I just realized I should go Cureko because
of the Zarya.
Oh, no.
I need to die so I can go Cureko.
Come on, Winston, you got this.
Oh, he booked everybody away, but that's okay.
That's okay.
He's gonna farm all over.
Oh, he already has also.
Oh, that is not okay.
That is not okay.
The war, we heal each other.
We heal each other.
That's right.
that all was useless we keep each other alive i need to
learn illari holy if she's gonna be meta and i don't need to
play illari or like uh learn how to play illari or um jesus
oh or like play with somebody that plays illari because holy
i don't know if i can learn illari in time that's the thing
Where's the Winston?
There he is.
Alright.
Yeah, it's more so balancing DPS and heals.
That's like the issue.
When I said he'll...
Oh, he bubbled!
That's cheating!
He bubbled!
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I need to, like, learn Illari.
Um...
off stream because like i can't learn her on stream are you
okay that he was way too aggressive for no reason jesus
please okay i'm okay i'm okay i have nano i couldn't swap
the it's okay
it's okay we're fine He's low, he's so low!
He's so dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh, we're so dead.
Mercy, I need you to keep me up where I get starstruck.
Whatever that alt is called.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going back, I'm going back.
Keep me up, keep me up!
I'm gonna go Kiriko for the grab!
I appreciate the support.
No, that's Alari.
He has all...
Oh, we don't have all...
This is bad.
I use cleanse.
Guys, I use cleanse!
This is bad!
It's okay, he's dead!
Oh, he went in so deep there.
It's okay, we're okay, we're okay.
We're fine, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Alright.
Has our widow done anything?
okay he has kills all right i just gotta be sure i couldn't
tell i need my cleanse for uh i need my cleanse for the oh
okay the mercy oh interesting pick interesting pick all
right this is where we die oh i don't know i don't know guys
i don't know Oh!
Goodbye Winston!
Oh shit!
Oh, okay, we're fine.
We're so safe.
Can we touch?
No, no, I have to go Lucio.
Get away!
Oh, I did my job!
I did my job!
I touched!
Nobody touched but me!
Nobody touched but me.
Oh, we don't have a Lari player because I don't play Lari
either.
Feels bad.
We don't have an Lari player.
My Lari is not at this level.
My Lari is sadly not this level.
Okay.
Hmm.
Let's see.
Yes.
Oh.
I don't think Kierko would be.
Oh, wait.
We have Hammond, so.
And we have Hammond.
I'll go.
Here we go.
Hammond is not good with Ana.
Because it's so hard to heal Hammond when he's so fucking
he's everywhere.
Apparently they've been talking about Hero Bands for fucking
ever.
So like I don't know.
That's the thing.
Hero Bands has been like they've always talked about Hero
Bands but they never actually implemented it.
They tried an Overwatch League but then they didn't do
anything about it.
So Hero Bans, like, it's like League.
You can ban a hero, basically.
It's just, it's just like League.
So that you just ban a hero that you don't want people to
play.
So you ban, like, I don't know, both teams cannot play,
like, Diva or something.
But, like, they always, they've done it before.
I don't know if you guys remember it, but they've done it
before.
This is not the first time they've done Hero Bans.
Hero Bans was, like, a thing.
before it was like a long time ago where they try like each
week each week they banning new hero
jesus he did so much damage i think her hammond's fucking
dead
oh no maybe it was easier for anna for you to play something
that's not maybe it's better if you don't play anna because
he's eating everything eating all your heals all your names
sorry man sorry buddy oh no the moment i looked away the
moment i looked away all right i have i think i don't know
it's just a team diff like i'm not playing a lorry which
sucks for our team because like i feel like my lorry is much
more of a uh Much more of a debuff than a natural buff.
Alright, um, I don't have cleanse.
But he missed.
He fucking missed.
Nerd.
He actually missed.
What a loser.
Oh.
There you go.
You're alive.
You're fucking...
Alright, somebody killed us Anna.
Okay, no?
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Nobody wants to kill the Anna.
But...
This is It's time I think it's not winnable So it's time to
learn I don't think this is winnable But it's time It's time
to learn
There you go Woo Oh he has Diva boss
Oh Really
All right, where did you go?
What the fuck?
Okay, that's not fair.
There's two of you guys It's time to learn a lorry no this
team There's no saving this I don't we're all just bad This
is just is literally our where I'm it just feels like an
uphill battle but I feel like we're not even gonna get that
we're not even gonna get the uphill battle that's good thank
you guys
whoo I'm just gonna try and cat claim claim the land
please live i'm trying to learn how to play larry live get
in there get
in there i'm gonna put this fucking here they can't get that
right yeah
all right get in there he's one he's one let's go God!
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where is this?
Where is the bomb?
I don't even know where the bomb was!
That was the worst part!
I was like, where is the...
No, give me the off charge, you fucking idiot!
Okay.
I literally could have got free off charge.
That's the worst part.
I could have got free off charge there.
oh god
okay well i got pylon up here so it won't get healed this is
this is it this is your chance all right goodbye cassidy oh
hello oh goodbye cassidy we tried we literally tried our
best he out damaged my fucking fly i don't know why he kept
saying there, but, like, okay.
Wee!
Alright.
But we're, me and the other support is doing so much
healing.
Yeah, he could have backed off?
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Is that...
You know, doesn't that seem, like, logical?
But, like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe I just haven't played this game enough.
Maybe.
Maybe I just haven't played this game enough, apparently.
oh god thank guys we're gonna stay here how do i keep what
why wait why why did they all went why did they okay nothing
makes sense nothing makes sense in this game nothing makes
sense in this game
i don't know all right we we gotcha who do we avoid who do
we not want on our team in the end out of everybody we pat
we fought oh my gosh not even uphill battle that's the worst
part is that i don't know why that's my thing the guy nano
nano visored to like one guy the guy nano visored one person
and then our kiriko tp'd to the nano visor and i was so
confused i was like if you stayed under with the soldier and
i maybe she just wants to die like maybe she really really
wanted to wanted to die there just wanted to die a little
faster i remember who gamma is so i guess goodbye gamma you
know what okay we'll we'll we'll we'll clean it up um who do
we hate the most who did we hate the most team the team who
do we not want our team the most guys maybe maybe our are
the other support because they don't know how to play larry
me the tank okay the tank all right goodbye tank goodbye
goodbye they were they were all bad like i don't know how to
pick they were all pretty terrible players as a team we were
all pretty terrible together as a team there was just
nothing man there was nothing i couldn't do anything about
it
couldn't play larry i was not the alari player i mean i
could try playing larry now maybe i'll start training alari
now oh you saw that headshot though i fucking ran away like
a little bitch like a fucking little bitch boy oh oh my god
another fucking running player five oh my god i'm getting
shot by both angles the larry training arc this is it
whoa please i there were three people on my screen i got
confused my fucking okay i need to like heal myself first i
feel like you have like a heal beam
oh okay like i'll take that you know
oh oh they're all dead okay okay they're all dead all right
all right no my god Junker Queen, really?
Where's Bap?
Oh, no!
No!
You can't, I can't jump back!
Oh my god, that was so smart!
He fucked me up.
He was smarter.
He was smarter than me.
Sucks.
Would you hate it when they're just smarter than you?
really get away leave the rock oh that's fucking right leave
leave the rock this is my rock oh this is my rock oh this is
not my rock anymore you can have it you can you can have the
rock i don't want it Rock was too scary.
Bro, what the fuck is this tank?
Let's get away.
What is this tank versus tank fight?
Wee-o.
You fucked this guy in particular.
No!
Apparently to activate it, he has to have, like, taken a
specific amount of damage.
Fuck that one.
one guy in particular though.
What's that?
Is that my pylon?
Whoa!
That's fucked up.
That's evil.
Oh my gosh!
I keep forgetting that doesn't heal.
I want to use that as like a heal for escape ability, but it
doesn't do that.
I got eliminated by cringe.
Why do you hate it when they eliminate you by cringe?
What the fuck?
That's right.
Get headshot.
Get headshot, bitch.
Nice.
Come
on.
Let me kill this guy first.
Come on.
Yeah, that's right.
Should have shot my pylon.
That's fucking right.
Wait, where did my pylon go?
Oh, there.
whoops no my fight line
what the fuck who's that where did the cure code come from
please give me a support that plays illari oh my god masters
2 okay getting a little serious now master 2 is top 500
getting a little more serious All right.
Can I go?
Senata?
I can't believe it.
The Kierko came in to protect me.
Like, where the fuck did the Kierko come from?
It's, like, out of nowhere.
Literally, turn around, and then the Kierko popped up.
But though the objects are subject to the same acceleration,
the thread between them snaps.
Fascinating.
One more mission, huh?
I'm in.
Alright, here we go.
Oh god, I hope they don't play Sigma.
If they play Sigma, I'm gonna fucking swap.
I hate playing Zignata against a Sigma.
It's like the worst.
I hope the enemy team knows I have a Sigma.
Zignata against Sigma is not fun to play because of the
shield.
Like, I can't shoot anything.
The shield refresh is just too good.
Oh, Ryan.
I can play Ryan.
Yeah, Ryan.
is pretty good against sigma i mean against
he cleansed it oh no not the mora i'm trying i'm trying how
did he die how do what how do we lose two already how do we
lose two people already oh he fucking actually deflected
that.
That's actually crazy.
We already lost two people.
Oh.
Alright, come on.
It's just a run.
He's just walking there.
He missed!
He missed the walking!
Wait, what?
DPS?
Oh, no, DPS.
DPS!
We're coming over, DPS!
He's low, he's low!
Where did Lucio go?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, he's just wall riding.
That's fine, let him wall ride!
Let him run!
EPS, please.
No, he's literally one.
I'm so sad.
He was literally one.
Alright.
I have alt soon.
Wait, I'm alt before the on?
Oh, wait, no, because he swapped.
I was going to say.
How the fuck do I have alt before?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's just refreshing me.
We're going to have more alts.
And maybe, Rhino?
Maybe?
I don't know.
I don't know if he's actually been doing much.
But I have to not get shattered.
That's like the hardest thing.
Just don't get shattered.
Okay.
Wait, what?
I mean...
I'm okay.
I'll take it.
Wait, what?
Try not shatter.
Still?
I'm scared.
I'm scared of this cry.
Don't worry!
I won't!
I cannot.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a miracle worker
I'm not a miracle worker I could take it for him I tried I'm
right in front of it I did you not see me right in front of
it I actually ran in front of it, but I couldn't.
Oh no.
Alright, I swap.
I'll go to Kierko.
Everybody's too split.
It doesn't matter.
Everybody's way too split.
For Senyada.
I might be getting kills, but it doesn't matter.
I need help.
Can you try to get to you?
We're here.
She's just dead.
Get shattered!
Oh, that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
We're trying.
I'm trying my best.
oh that's fucked up we're trying our best to keep you up oh
my god please live everybody you're all so separated
you're all so separated
Oh god, I'm trying everything I can to keep you all up.
Please!
Jesus, leave!
Oh, we're alive.
We're alive.
It's okay.
It's okay, we're okay.
That's why I went here to go.
Like, I might have been killing people at Zenyatta, but
everybody was everywhere.
There was no point.
Everybody was just everywhere!
Where do I go?
Here, there you go.
There you go.
Chunk.
I don't know why I said Jack.
Zero one, zero one.
You're alive.
Live!
Guess that's it.
That's one.
What the fuck?
Give me up!
No!
Jack, Rack.
Please.
Why do we not have a single kill?
I know what an epic.
After all of that, we don't have a single kill after all of
that.
It's actually so sad.
How do we not have a kill?
I felt like, oh my god, junk rat.
Holy sh- Oh, oh, two, two down, two down.
Go, go, go.
Two down.
We're faster.
Literally two down.
Oh, no.
He doesn't have grab.
There's no way.
He'll have it in the next fight, I think.
There's no fucking...
way he gets grabbed there okay oh my god there it is there
it is there it is
live live please we're trying so hard to keep you up right
now please please live okay i had a feeling that was gonna
happen to you please no i can't out of here, I'm tired, if I
quit, I would!
I would.
Oh, no.
Please.
I can touch.
I can maybe touch.
Zara won.
We got on!
But...
I don't know how I can live!
Touch!
No, the orb!
The orb!
The fucking orb!
Junkrat it's you!
Go!
Junkrat, go!
Oh, it's over.
I can't believe it!
The orb wasn't even for me!
We needed no bubbles in our back line, and we just don't
care.
It wasn't even Targeted at me!
That's the worst part!
Holy shit.
That was actually the worst part.
That the orb wasn't targeted to me.
I don't know.
I don't know where to play.
Hmm.
I guess I'll go Kiriko.
I...
This team is not organized at all.
This team fucking...
I know.
I don't know.
Maybe it's time.
Maybe it's time to learn Alari.
This team is not organized.
All right.
One life.
One life with Alari.
All right.
One life.
I'm gonna avoid the junk rat though.
That.
You are not a journalist.
Put it here.
What's this?
It's like.
this team is all over the place we're not playing together
that's the thing the scene does not play together at all so
it's like really difficult to heal like I have to like
follow one I can only heal one person I have to choose
wisely yeah the junk riot is definitely not doing it no I
don't think they got anything with their all at all oh nice
all right
Oh shit, I'm trying!
No!
Alright, I used my one life.
I'll go Kiriko now.
I used my one life.
This is full dive.
I'm hooking, I'm not...
I'm not playing Lari against full dive.
Oh, that's unlucky for me.
Oh no.
Please, please, please, please.
No!
I wanted to come back!
Oh, that's so unlucky.
Yeah, that was...
That was a hard...
Bro, where are you?
Where are you?
Where did he go?
Yeah, this is...
He's over there.
Oh, he fell.
Okay.
That works.
Okay, I don't know if we should chase, but okay.
Alright.
They're not gonna have any ults because that was such a fast
fight.
Oh, I'm doing my best.
Oh.
They have it all.
Separated us all.
Bro, what the fuck?
Why are they all ulting us?
We're dead!
Please, we're already dead!
We're literally already dead!
You don't need to keep going!
They have Genji ult though.
They have Genji ult.
We have nothing that can counter...
Hymen.
We have Sombra maybe?
I think we should get Sombra.
Honestly.
They have none.
Goodbye.
This is where we die.
Holy shit.
This team's the best.
We're the best right now.
Are we dying to die?
I have no healing.
We have a junk rat.
Guys.
Do you not see that we have a junk rat?
He could be the best junk rat in the world.
We still have it.
Oh, thank God.
This is a...
This area is junk, though.
at least.
Alright, there you go, Jump!
Yeah, but we don't have enough healers for Brig, Lucio.
That's the thing.
We're running, Lucio.
We don't have enough healers for that.
I have to run, like, a heal-intensive character, and I
either go Mora or Kiriko, but we need to cleanse.
Because of the Gengu.
Guys, we just need to hold this for four minutes!
That's fine!
Okay!
Let's just hold this for four minutes.
Oh, there you go.
They backed up.
I bought us some time, guys.
Guys, I bought us some time.
I'm Zara.
Oh, they were running Zara now.
That's okay.
Now we have...
They lost one fight.
They lost two fights.
Let's fight.
Oh my god.
That's good.
He lost his alt charge.
They just need one alt, though.
What the fuck was our tracer fighting her demons?
Okay, we have feet for a grab They're trying to rely on
nanoblade, I think oh and echo so Echo diva or some shit I
can't shoot because I don't want to die I don't want to die
so I'm heal body right now just peek up all right what the
fuck is going on right now get over get to get to get to get
to start get to start nice all right they still have nano
blade no they don't they just have blade
okay i don't want to fucking push that i'm not i'm not gonna
be in uh I'm not gonna fucking DPS if I die we're fucked
because I'm like the main healer so I have to play much more
safe you're gonna eat the ground Diva eat the ground what
the fuck okay two more minutes of this guys two more minutes
of this let's Go!
Oh, let's not go.
Let's not go, I guess.
All right.
Yeah, go run, go run.
They have no beat, no blade.
They miss grab.
I got you, I got you!
Don't worry, I got you!
Watch you!
two more minutes!
Two more minutes of hell!
I wanna swap?
Go!
Go, go!
Loose your taxi-em!
Loose your!
We need you!
Taxi!
Morgan!
No, we're at the point!
This is it!
This is the infamous tank counter-swap!
This is...
this is the infamous tank counter-swap battle!
This is it.
I told you guys the fable tank counter swap battle.
Oh my god.
One fight.
Hell has arrived.
Okay.
Is he gonna swap monkey?
Sigma versus Sigma.
Let's go!
He's shift already.
That rocks.
One minute left.
They need one fight.
They're gonna leave one fight.
Um, I don't know if they'll have Blaine.
Yeah, they'll have Coal.
Yeah, they'll have all the support.
All of us, I agree.
He's tired.
Oh god.
Not the orb.
No!
Oh god.
I'm...
It's fine!
Oh no, a blade!
I'm dead, I'm dead!
Where is he?
Oh no, it's not over!
It's actually not over!
That is not over!
Come on, come on, come on, come on!
Oh god.
How is it?
Very soldier man.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this game?
This is what I mean.
It's the battle of the counter swaps.
The battle of the counter swap.
What a fucking game oh my god what a game okay that was a
good game that was actually a really good game that was
insane holy shit oh we deserve that we fucking deserve that
so much like our takes were just the takes were just counter
swapping the battle of the counter swaps that was insane I
saw so many different tanks today from one game from one
game I saw a million tanks I hate learning a larry you bet
you just play with a support player I plays a larry
I was I thought I was curicle for one second that's why I
threw my pylon that shit was ridiculous yeah he literally
went back to zone uh to point just to it went back to
respawn just to swap this is what i'm seeing all these tanks
that's all they do the world of tanks
no my pilot that's up no stop stop yeah that was ridiculous
holy that was intense though I was gonna avoid the junk but
he he clutched it he clutched it when it mattered you know
what let me go oh no oh no that's right no my life my baby
oh no please please leave me alone i don't have anything
I'm literally poor.
Oh, I hear junk.
Oh, he left.
Yay, it's just me.
Oh, my God.
It's so scary.
Come on.
I hear him.
Don't worry.
I have my pylon.
I...
Yeah!
I still have my pylon.
That's right.
Tomato.
I thought it was tomato.
I was like, oh my god.
I fight myself.
Oh, I hear...
Oh, that's an ash.
I thought that was a widow.
The only issue is just the wait time.
But, like, I understand we need...
Oh, no.
No!
My pylon!
Not my pylon!
No, my pylon!
what okay I give him that I'm a solo alt somebody but not me
because it'll not be worth it alright Tomoto where are you
where the fuck are you I just solo alt you where are you
Tomoto where fuck are you oh my god this is the five stack
in here that's fucking right no yes no He's the only one!
He's the only one!
Look this.
I'm done.
I'm never gonna learn Illari.
Oh, the game was like, you're done too.
You're...
Even the game was like, you're done.
Select your hero.
all right let's see is like everyone playing mercy because
like they have a mercy icon is it weird that like every time
i see a mercy icon i instinctually went mercy it's not bad
right oh no they have mercy everything all right prove me
wrong They proved me wrong!
They're an Anna player!
Oh my god!
This is why you don't judge a book by its cover, guys.
This is exactly why.
Because I'm gonna play him for sure.
The battle was behind.
Are you a console player, Batman?
I know.
This is why...
You don't judge a book by its cover, guys!
You're like...
I'm gonna play Anna one life and then I'm gonna play Mercy
Because this I should have been playing Mercy on this map
Mercy is really good at defense on this This specific point
Because Because like of the verticality Oh yeah I stole
their Anna Wait I shouldn't have to play Wait you're right I
stole their one trick Whoops Really?
I was like I'm fucking dead.
I'm like, I brought...
I bring him down with me, though.
Okay, I...
I like that I said that, and I'm like, I'm going to steal
the round.
Sorry, that's my bad.
Accidental throwing, guys.
Are they not capping the point?
You're still here.
You know what?
No, this guy needs to learn.
It can't be a one-trick.
I need...
I'm
dead.
No!
Why is everybody not playing together?
I'm throwing because I took over.
I took away their Anna
That was my bad I forgot whoops goodbye No, I wanted to
punch the stop side away
Nah, that's not bad No, I'm only the second support was
playing his mate.
I just went use the nano and then I swear I'm not even doing
a lot of healings that's swamp I'm sorry Juggs I'm sorry
I'll just be a curicle one trick yeah are they okay oh wait
he's one he's literally one
What?
Why all didn't go off?
I was so confused.
Are you serious?
Okay, JK.
Sorry, that was embarrassing.
That was actually embarrassing.
I hit it!
But he's dead anyway!
Go, go, go!
I'm throwing.
I'm actually throwing.
I don't want to play Anna anymore.
I'm sorry.
I just throw it.
It's my fault.
I would admit I threw this entire game.
I would admit that.
I take 100% responsibility.
.
shit okay but like even when i swap guys like i don't know
guys i think it's just a team issue it's not just me guys i
don't think it's just me guys
it's okay we have next game we i know when i'm throwing guys
Guys, I think I should have went Mercy, guys.
I will go Mercy during an attack.
Holy shit, we're getting absolutely destroyed.
Jesus.
Oh, he fucking was not there.
I thought he'd be there earlier.
Chunk is still one, guys.
Chunk is not one anymore!
It's okay, I'm here.
I would admit I threw the first the first point in the
second point
I don't know I forgot that he's an animated I took Anna from
him oh my god Whoops.
I'll be on mercy duty.
Are you up?
Are you down?
Very down.
Wait, who said that?
Three to Masters Five.
Hey, y'all.
Okay, uh...
I'm avoiding him.
Yeah.
Like in one session or like...
Don't worry.
I'll be right behind you.
Guys, I don't think it's me.
We were up in the...
At first.
We were up at first.
Guys, I don't think it's me.
I know.
He went from... How?
Did you guys hear what you said?
You guys heard it, right?
Did you hear what he said?
Oh.
He went from Masters 3 to Masters 5.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He said he went from Masters 3 to Masters 5 in one session,
guys.
That's what he said.
He's been playing and he went down two ranks.
There are only two rings!
This team is cooked.
This team is actually fully cooked, guys.
Oh no.
Is our Ash gonna be okay?
Oh, our Genji's not gonna be okay.
Oh, please!
I needed help too!
get shot by five different people okay let me respect it let
me see uh there's no there's no wait what's the voice chat
volume where's the voice chat volume i can't find it bro
needs to stop dude he does this guy needs to stop this is
not top 500 easy anymore for this man he is getting doom
dipped hard I don't even know if I could rent him I don't I
don't know oh my god I tried to scrape away goodbye oh
goodbye whoa he chased me
Oh, yep, you can search it in the settings?
Wait, you can search?
Okay.
Alright, no, this is just GG's.
It doesn't matter.
This whole team is fucked.
Sorry, I avoid...
We might be able to farm this one guy.
We might...
We might be able to farm him.
That's...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I think this team is...
We're all special.
It's not just me.
I admit, I threw.
But it's not just me.
Okay.
I admit, but it's definitely not just me.
Yeah.
Yeah, we did it.
We finally killed Doom!
We fucking did it!
We did it, guy!
We made it!
Whoa.
Whoa, shit!
Please somebody kill this junk rat!
Somebody, please let me...
Somebody, please!
Don't worry, I will alt when we need it.
We need it.
Okay.
All right All right, okay Oh
Goodbye everybody I'm trying no I hit it Oh my god I did my
job I did what I needed to do this entire team was just not
workable like do that anymore this entire team it was a mess
i was i would admit i was also a mess but it was a group
effort it was it was a group effort of it was actually it
was not just me my entire team was just a mess
a mess of group effort we all we all did not deserve to win
that i mean the moment i heard this doom player when yeah i
went from master 3 to master 5 and like master 3 to master 5
and the other guy was like in one session and i knew the
moment he said that i knew it was over.
I knew it.
Oh, hey, it's him!
Alright, please don't make me be the one to break his win
streak.
If I break this man's win, like, if I, sorry, if I break
this man's lost streak, that's the last game for me.
That's the...
That's my last game.
Okay, I No, he plays Doom.
I want to go Kiriko.
He plays Doom.
Oh, I haven't.
I don't want to play Ana if he's playing Doom.
I'll play I get Kiriko.
What works well with me?
That actually works great.
Okay, good.
Alright.
I'll run Kiriko.
I don't want to play...
I don't want to play Ana against Doom.
It's just not fun.
Kiriko is the only fun character to play against Doom.
If I make this man lose his last streak, it's over for me.
I'm fucking done for the day.
I'm so done for the day.
That's when I know.
It's just...
Today's just over.
Come on, kill him!
He's solo!
Yes.
Thank God.
Please, let me just farm him.
There you go.
I can clean.
I can touch the spot here.
I'm in.
No, heaven!
All right.
This is a little worrying now.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry, man.
All right.
we can't really touch but we're trying so hard to keep you
alive we're trying so hard oh he fucked up oh but he's one
he's literally one god he's so low oh it doesn't matter he's
not low anymore it doesn't matter I live I live guys I think
this doom is really bad Even if we lose This doom is not a
good doom player I think I think this doom is actually
pretty fucking terrible Like not gonna lie He is not a good
doom player Oh okay Like you Like it's so It's so noticeable
too It's actually so noticeable Like...
Mario literally won.
It's really noticeable.
Yeah.
I played...
The fact that I played against an...
I played against like several good Doomplay already.
No, 100%.
That's a little embarrassing that he fucking...
Whoa!
Tiki!
Oh, there is one.
Like...
I'm still alive.
I don't know, man.
That's fine.
Oh my god, alright.
We need to kill this Mercy.
We really need to kill.
Alright, here we go.
All right, I need to stop fucking rushing me.
I was trying to stay alive for the longest time.
Okay, nice.
We got the mercy.
Bro, he's so low!
Oh, no.
No!
Okay, we have one fight.
No, but their doom is not good.
The doom is literally getting carried by his DPS.
His DPS is good.
But his DPS is good.
good but the tube is so bad like it's actually fucking
terrible oh my god actually terrible oh no no that's so
unlucky for him i still got it off okay
come on Come on, May!
Come on, May!
I can't do anything right now.
Ah, keep fighting.
You're literally getting hard carried by DPS.
I need to keep...
Nice, okay.
Nice.
Nice!
Holy shit!
No one's even...
Yeah.
Literally, he's getting carried our DPS and support but yeah
oh my god bro they're tank man they're tank I want to farm
this tank so badly I want to farm this tank so badly holy
fuck
I don't understand how he dropped from Master 3 to 5.
I understand now.
It's...
Holy shit.
I think that's like the worst Doom I've ever seen in this
Elo.
100%.
I've never seen a Doom that bad in this Elo.
I think he has to be learning.
There's no...
I refuse to believe.
Oh my god, thank god.
He finally...
He needed to swap.
He 100% needed a swap doom.
He needed- he could not be playing that character.
He- He should not be playing that character.
100%.
Jesus Christ.
Cool.
Oh my god, I can't heal the fucking Hammond.
They're just like, we don't have our Hammond to help us.
okay come on come on Hammond come on Hammond I'm going I'm
trying to save you we gotta pick guys somebody push
okay oh all right there we go they got like 30 you know
that's good that he swapped like it was just embarrassing
you know it was just it was just embarrassing like he needed
to swap he was he 100% needed to swap this character was so
scared for some reason not character tracer shit okay I'm
scared oh treasure one no I'm scared oh my god oh my god
Okay.
Oh, wait, no, I should stay because of my health.
I should...
What comes from?
Where the fuck did he come from?
Oh my god, what's the right for that?
Wait, what?
Missed the grapple, though.
Oh, no.
No!
I timed it incorrectly.
That was my bad.
I timed it incorrectly Oh my god I timed my E I was like Oh
I should E but then I'm like Nope but I got greedy I got so
greedy I'm just glad he's not playing doom anymore Holy shit
Yeah I waited too long I was so surprised Oh wait he went on
okay That goes down then
Alright it's time It's time It's time?
It's time?
Oh god.
Pog is answered.
It's time?
We're trying...
It's time.
Oh god.
No!
We didn't swap in time.
Alright, it's zen time.
It's zen.
Nobody gets their ult?
You know, we just didn't have ults.
Alright, Zen time.
Alright.
I just don't think we should have Ren.
We definitely should not.
We should have stopped using Hammond.
Is this guy a Hammond one trick?
Am I losing because I have a Hammond one trick on my team?
Is that it?
Is this it?
Mine.
Because he can't swap?
Oh, he doesn't go voice chat.
Oh, okay.
There might be...
This might be it.
Prosperity.
No, but they have...
Yeah, but like...
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna be like...
Oh, no.
Alright.
Let's shred this hog.
I just bully this hog, I guess.
And she's not even like a good pig.
It's just that...
Okay.
Um, I can't see the tank anywhere.
Oh, he might die here.
Oh, oh, he's dead though, but I am solo healing.
No, he got it!
No, they hooked!
Wait, you're not going!
Okay, if you're gonna go Mercy, All right.
All right.
I have to go Anna for the end.
Guys, this might be last game.
Guys, I said if I break this guy's lost streak, we're
calling it.
That's when I know it's over.
Lost because I had, even though this guy was a terrible Doom
player, I have a Hammond one trick.
Whoa, no hook.
No hook.
We should push up.
we have one pick there you go hog's half no breather
he's somebody's anti there guys we have to contest point
guys guys please
yes oh no he's doing so much death why didn't this doom
fucking play other characters in my Thank you!
Oh, this is not good for us.
Oh, alright.
Oh.
Goodbye, May.
Alright.
I mean, that's cool.
I anti-timed, though.
That's cool, too.
Alright, nice.
Oh!
Please!
He's one!
Oh, he doesn't have res.
Oh, thank God.
Guys, we have one fight if they capped it.
Oh.
Guys, that was a good last game, chat.
You know.
They might have...
The guy actually learned to swap off Doom.
But sadly, for us, our damon doesn't know how to swap out
when he clearly is not it.
But yet, sadly, our other tank does not know that concept,
unfortunately.
Unfortunately, that is not a concept that he knows of.
Get him!
The Doom player finally got his big brother that knows how
to play other heroes.
Like...
I think he got the big...
The big brother that actually knows how to counter swap.
He fucking swapped to heaven!
What the fuck?
This is not fair.
I want him to live.
I'm expecting him to live right now.
He's literally nanoed.
Oh, guys.
That's all that matter.
What?
How did that not hit the anti?
The fact that the anti didn't hit there was crazy.
Ornithade.
Maru1.
Oh my god, there you go.
Please!
I slept him!
I slept him, guys!
Please!
I never sleep!
Oh no, you clearly won!
Oh my god, wait, we did it, yay!
Yay!
His loss streak continues!
Oh!
Oh my god, thank god!
His loss streak continues!
That's all I care.
That's all I care about.
I'm glad he keeps losing.
yeah keep going down let me keep farming you oh my god how
long are you streaming four hours this is what happens in
overwatch you just keep playing it's so hard to quit oh my
god it's nine oh my god it's so hard to quit guys
oh we keep going i'm still on master five hey i didn't rank
for master three to master five up i'm almost i almost got
to master four but like and then i started losing so yeah
and then i i lost the points i gained so you know you win
some you lose some it's the way of overwatch sadly overwatch
you just don't win you don't win no matter what because
you're playing the game
what do you mean i'm master five right now see i'm literally
master five oh my god i'm almost i almost play 150 games do
i really want to win i will call in a duo to play tank and
all i do is just nano them like
that's literally it That's the way to climb for real.
I just need to call it a duo tank or a duo Illari.
Alright, next game.
Oh, it's not him!
Master 5 and Master 3.
Okay.
It's getting more competitive.
Yeah, you win by making other people lose.
Push.
I thought I avoided.
I had so many games that are not push.
That I enjoyed.
I had so many games that I was so happy about.
But like, I guess, you know, happiest gotta stop somewhere.
I had to stop feeling happy today.
Like, it knew.
The game knew.
The game was like, it's time to stop being happy.
We want you to play a push map now.
It's so sad.
Siri, please play Despacito.
I hate...
Yeah, I played a new push map.
I played it.
No happy.
You're right.
Nobody's actually happy when they played Overwatch.
And the best game I had was the last game, because of my...
Because I finally slept...
Slept some players.
And also that Kiriko match against that really fucking good
Doom player.
Oh no.
Not this thing.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I'm not playing Senata.
I'm not playing Senata.
They literally have Hammond, and...
That is not a fun company.
That is not fun.
That is actually not fun.
That is, like...
It's time to stop having fun.
Alright.
Two bully Senata players for this.
Can I go with...
Alright, I'm gonna play Mora.
I'm gonna play Mora.
Hey.
Ana, you should swap.
You're not going to have fun.
You're 100% not going to have fun.
They literally have Sombra.
Sombra Hammond.
That's the day that fun died.
Oh, he was so low, too.
Oh, nice.
The day Spun had died.
Are they still pushing?
Oh, shit.
It's okay, I got you.
It's okay.
He's still alive?
Alright.
We run away.
I am not playing any non-mobile characters.
Also, I'm tired of playing on Kiriko.
This Ana can swap to Kiriko if he wants to.
I'm fucking tired of Kiriko.
I played so much Kiriko today.
Because nobody else was playing Kiriko.
It sucks.
Whenever they have an honor, you'll have to play Kiriko for
the cleanse.
So, like, nobody's happy.
No one gets to be happy!
Oh, no.
Please, please.
Just touch.
There we go.
Nice.
Get him out!
All right.
Thank you, Anna.
Goodbye, Anna.
I did not think, you know, you would actually die.
Goodbye.
Holy shit, the enemy team is actually anti-fun.
This is like the most anti-fun team I've ever seen.
Fucking...
Sombra, Mora, Hammond.
That is so anti-fun.
Oh my god.
Well, I just want to know why I'm tapping.
Because you regen your heals faster.
You tap.
Alright.
I'm going to do something stupid.
I'm going to do something really stupid.
They're all gone.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
I can't heal you guys.
there that's good that's good i'm gonna keep you up so you
can no guys i tried all right we did a nano oh our other
team got separated by the ham and please somebody play
sombra anybody play sombra break does nothing against this
cop because they have a sombra
easy to counter anti-fun!
We just need a Sombra!
That's literally it!
If we want to counter anti-fun!
Just go Sombra!
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, man.
But like, I'm fucking...
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
This team You know, the best thing about Push is a curse But
the best thing about push is that when your team is garbage
It ends faster So thank God Thank God for that And people
were like Oh why don't you play Why don't you play break
Because they literally have Sombra And like all Sombra has
to do is hack me And I'm fucking useless That's why it's
like We need We need We need our own team, Sombra, to just
make the Hammond, like, swap.
Because the Hammond's the problem.
Catch it!
Come down!
Literally, that's it!
I'm always running out because I can't build charge!
Oh, God, Diva, please, Diva.
I will not have enough charge for you.
Please, I literally...
Diva, please.
Please, Diva.
Please, catch the orb.
Oh, no.
No!
No, Anna!
I got you, Anna!
Please!
Wait, where's our fucking ash?
When the fuck did he ash?
You play Reaper, but not Sombra?
Okay.
I'm not blaming the tank.
I'm blaming our DPS.
The easiest counter to Hammond is a Sombra.
And all he has to do is hack him 24-7.
So he cannot be...
You don't have to be useful.
You just hack him.
That's literally it.
You don't even have to be useful.
You just hack him.
You run Reaper, but not Sonic.
bruh he's clearly willing to swap
our tank our tank there's nothing he can do unless he runs
like i don't know i don't know what he can run as a tank but
like we can do something about this hammond
who are you gonna you see that you see that i mean our tank
who are you gonna shoot us through Pretty fast!
Bro, he understands!
You're funny!
I'm like, I thought so too!
What a funny issue!
At least I'm not the only one that's going, huh?
He knows!
Even he knows!
Even he's like, what the fuck?
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Oh my god.
That's on him.
Jesus Christ.
I need my fucking charge here.
I'm just gonna do this to fucking survive.
Okay!
Um...
Oh, my!
Yes, I'm just gonna suck a little harder here!
Just gonna push it.
Goodbye, goodbye.
I'll see you later.
Goodbye.
Let the push commence.
I get to push it a little more.
Wow!
Okay, everybody chased.
It's okay, I got like...
I was able to push it back.
That's all that matters.
What the fuck is wrong with this?
Oh shit.
Oh my god, our team.
Bro, bro, how?
How?
We are trying our fucking best.
You're on Reaper.
when you went from you're literally on Reaper and I'm
surprised her Ana is still on Ana after like this world of
pain I'm just surprised he's still willing to go fucking Ana
it's not fun there's a reason why I'm not playing fucking
Ana it's It's not fun at all.
This is like, yeah, like I said, it's literally anti-fun.
Oh my god.
Okay.
See, this is all you do, you hack!
You hack!
That literally could be you!
That's literally you!
That's literally you out of...
Okay, we gotta go in there.
Are you serious?
No, I died of all!
I didn't think I was gonna get hit, but I didn't see the
dynamite!
Please, Anna, please, I've made you, I've let you live for
so long, I need you to live.
I didn't see the dynamite.
I was trying to hide.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, everybody is so critical.
No, no, no.
Catch the orb!
I can't get to people!
Oh god.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
Now he's-
Bro!
Nice!
What?
No, no, I have- I can't.
I cannot play with a C.
I see Sombra now!
I see Sombra!
Okay, we're in a C.
Who is the Reaper?
The fuck?
Is there everything we've been through?
You a Sombra now!
Oh!
Did you see how impressive their Sombra was?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was the most...
That was the game of all time.
That was truly the game of all time.
Is there a gun game?
I haven't seen like an actual gun game.
Oh wait, no, it's an arcade.
I forgot.
They like took away gun game in custom and put it in an
arcade.
That sucks.
I wish there was gun game in, um, waiting for Q.
Oh my god.
That was, that was the worst.
That was actually the worst.
Alright, this is my last game for real, though.
Loss or win.
This is my last game for real.
That's fun, though.
I love Overwatch, Rank.
Because when you don't take it seriously.
Despite how much I was raging, I was not taking seriously.
This is This is my last game for real though Let's see We'll
practice sleep dart We'll practice our sleep darts Can I not
lost?
Yes That's a bait That's a bait to make you like fucking
play this game forever You can't fool me You can't fucking
fool me guys Because then you're like Oh if I win you guys
would be like Oh but you can't like You can't just like
Ended, uh, you can't just end on a, uh, on a win streak.
And then it's a cycle.
You guys can't fool me.
Because I was, I, I know that experience.
You can't fool me.
Is this, uh, how many points do you have to do?
Four minutes?
Okay.
Ooh.
Oh!
you had to hit that one shot I swear if I got like hit by
that I need to get a sleep dart where is he we whoa no no I
can't shoot down no
nice that's fucking right how do you What's the winning
point?
Why is there...
Oh, they added a bot that advertises their Discord.
What?
You won because of ping.
Am I mugged melee?
No, I'm cha-cha.
Okay.
It's so hard to sleep.
Because, like...
It's much easier to just shoot your gun.
Where are you?
That's fucking right.
Are you behind me?
Hello?
That's right.
Where am I?
They didn't see that.
Alright.
Master 5 to Master 4.
Let's go.
Alright, let's see.
Fen All right, I want to play Ana Since we're playing Ana
Literally one is an actual It's an actual Fuck what's the
word It's an actual player's name I remember Before like
Streamer mode was a thing This is an actual player name This
is it I got waffle on tank Who is waffle man Remember waffle
man Let's see In my game yeah isn't i see also a pro name
yeah but i see is a dps player this is not the real i see
there's no way is this a real i see playing fucking mora no
this is a mora me yeah guys i don't think this is the same i
see guys i i this is i see the mora one trick holy
I don't think that's the same icy.
Mmm, Widow.
Ooh, oh, King ending the game on the best map in Overwatch.
That's great.
I like that.
I like that they're ending it here.
I love...
I love, uh...
Oh, that's fucking shit.
There's...
They have...
This is bad because they have Anna.
Mora!
What are you doing, Mora?
Goodbye.
Woo!
Somebody do something about the tank!
Nice.
Yay!
That's right, you can't do a shit!
Nice.
because usually there are tanks will do like an honorable
ride 1v1 but like our our waffle man is not honorable you
can tell oh they swapped off swapped off widow which is nice
so i can i don't have to worry about peeking now i can peek
forever oh oh all right that sucks oh he's one he's one what
okay
Where did he come from?
Oh,
my shit.
I know what?
Okay, that's a good Allari player.
Oh, my God.
Really?
How did he jump scared me?
Actual jump scare.
He has shatters soon.
We gotta go on.
I'm gonna...
Oh, God.
Oh god, we lost the doom though, we got We need to get on
point No, it's at point Please Do we not have all?
Oh, Ash did not have all Yeah, never mind Ash did not have
all
Holy shit
That could be me That could be me That Aulari is insane.
This is what I mean.
If you do have a good Aulari.
Aulari.
Because a good Aulari can fucking carry.
If you do have a good Aulari and Aulari a good tank player.
It doesn't matter what role you are.
You can carry so hard.
Or you can climb so hard.
Maybe I should have nanoed the Doom.
I just went with the first person I see.
I see.
If you're gonna be a fucking...
Oh.
Actually fuck off.
Guys!
I told you!
I can sleep!
I told you I could sleep!
Oh, he missed me.
Ash!
You're lucky I'm fucking pre-healing you!
Alright, Ash!
I'm fucking leaving Ash.
I'm gonna heal somebody else.
That was a good decision by me.
Told you guys I can... I know how to fucking... I know how
to sleep!
Bro, is this kid?
That's a child!
Or a girl.
That sounded like... I can't tell.
I couldn't tell.
What's that, child?
I can't tell.
Oh, that's a widow.
Okay.
You gotta come over here.
Maybe both.
Could be.
Oh, God.
Please, he's one.
He's one.
No!
It sounded like a child.
Stop them.
Hedro.
Hello.
I think he started to say Helomura?
I think he was.
I think.
It would have been so sick.
Heal the headshot?
I can't.
Okay, no, it's not a child.
You get headshot, I can't heal that, bro.
Never mind.
Not a child.
Just a southern accent.
Definitely not a child.
Bro.
No!
I jumped!
Never mind.
It's woman.
Sorry, I thought that was a child, but the southern accent
threw me off the southern accent threw me off that's for
sure oh my all right not peeking the widow don't peek the
widow don't peek the widow oh this is where our rematra dies
unless This is definitely where I'm a much...
This is...
This is 100% where we...
When he dies, nothing can save him.
Oh my god!
Bye.
Goodbye.
I stay here.
Holy shit, he's taking so much damage.
We are trying our fucking best here.
Alright, go waffle.
Go!
Jesus.
Okay.
Go waffle.
Go!
What the fuck?
He's actually one!
I swear to God!
Where did he come from?
We don't fuck the waffle.
waffle cat that waffle the hanzo come from dude double
sniper is so scary is he still double sniper okay thank god
okay single sniper feels a lot more manageable though oh oh
and he's dead tight oh i off i go into the world of cover
whoa oh the widow's there we don't have to run we still What
do you mean?
We still need a run!
Okay.
It's... it's even.
Alright, there's nothing I can do with that.
Jeez.
Please.
Please, Winston.
I'm trying to kick you up right now.
Oh my god, Liv!
for me it's over it's okay we can push that far right it's
manageable guys in two hours i have the meeting i think i
played overwatch a little bit too long
i was not supposed to play overwatch this long but i
couldn't help it
It was just so fun.
Hey, guys, I canceled it, Ronald.
Okay?
I literally...
I'm gonna avoid this moral player forever.
It doesn't matter.
One trick should not exist in this game.
I'm gonna avoid her so that in the future, I don't bump into
this person.
It doesn't matter if she's good or not.
She's still a one trick.
I hate one tricks.
This game has...
Evolved to the point where one trick should not exist
anymore if you want to win Yeah, but I might be playing
tomorrow.
I'm trying to end top 500 this season
Yay Is literally the only sleep you hit that was the sleep
that mattered As it mattered it met no, I slept two people I
literally have stats on my screen You can't fucking gaslight
me.
They're literally numbers on my screen.
Ooh, that's a really good anti, though.
Alright.
That's a good Anna.
Because he knows his, um, maid.
I see a lot of fucking maid players right now.
Guys, break the wall!
I should not be the only one shooting that wall.
Like...
I actually should not be the only one.
Please.
Oh, come on.
God.
No, I had to reload.
I was so unlucky.
I literally had to reload.
Yeah, but they do have an honor, so it's a little risky.
Oh, he's shooting me.
So...
Oh, I thought he'd be there.
Bad prediction.
No.
Oh nice.
Oh no, that's not nice.
Not nice.
Nice.
Nice again.
Not nice.
Not nice at all.
Why did nobody come back?
Why did I die?
What the fuck?
Nobody came back.
Have I died?
I've been died for it?
Nobody came back for me.
Literally, I'll fucking take right out of me.
They forgot about me.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Their Ana's really good, though.
Because, like I said, they know, like, need loadouts.
Someone, please shoot the ice!
We have two TPS that can't shoot ice block.
Who's gonna nano the Bob?
Oh, who froze?
Nobody.
Okay.
Do we have a Bob?
But guys!
I...
Guys, how can three people just not shooter.
I, I, look at their HP.
No, our team's, oh my guys, I, I can't, I, let's see, I, I,
I don't understand how our team did not kill the me.
I, I don't, I don't understand, like, that was, I, I saw the
kill and that should not have happened.
Her HP was not going down fast enough.
Holy shit.
I got this at the last game.
No, why were you not against the wall?
I can't.
This game.
He has all.
The Romatra has all.
I can't.
This game, man.
I actually can't.
Oh, God.
Please.
Oh, the only reason I use it is to keep you alive.
Oh, God.
Oh, come on.
Oh, you fucked this team.
This team is very special because it is my team.
I feel like I should go Kiriko for the cleanse, but like, I
feel like we definitely need that, Anna.
Are you...
He's one.
He's...
He's so low.
I see...
Oh god.
Thursday.
Please.
Hanzo, please.
oh my god i feel like we definitely need we need the fucking
please don't stand there please they have a widow please
please i do not please they have a widow i do not feel good
of you standing there like that it makes me so uncomfortable
he has all two oh he's so low but oh he altered him He has
all the Reaper has all I can feel it He has all two
Please Where the fuck is the Reaper?
Oh, he's back there Alright, he's gone Reaper's gone Whoa
That's the patch What is the patch That he's mad about Which
one is it
Thing is, I don't know what he's mad about.
I don't know which patch.
There's so many things to be mad about, but I don't know
which one.
God, I don't want to look at him.
Oh, they're going hog counters now.
Oh, they went maga.
Oh, they want to win.
Let's fuck it.
Get this maga out of our game.
Get him out of our game, please.
That's all I want.
Get this guy out of our game.
Get him out.
Okay.
Yay!
That's fucky, right?
I sleep to win that on.
that reaper waited his entire life for that all that's so
that's where he came from the sleep that mattered baby he
waited his entire he kept that sleep for so fucking long
making ggs dog shit reaper i wonder if that's when i play
the game i hope it is okay history kings row i want to see
that oh no not save I want to...
I want to see that.
Ended on a win.
Is it?
Is that...
Hello, C.F.
Coker.
It is.
Ha ha ha ha.
Embarrassing for the Reaper.
So embarrassing.
Holy shit.
That shit is so embarrassing for him.
Rip bozo.
That's fun.
I have fun time.
We're up.
I think I need like one game and I'd be master four.
But we're up.
I mean, it's pretty good for solo queue, honestly.
For solo queue in general, that's like pretty good for me.
Being up is always good, guys.
No matter what, as long as you're like as long as you're
positive in your climb, that's all that matters.
So I'm happy.
I'm happy that we're positive in the climb.
yeah just one i was i did have a lot of fun i always have a
lot of fun when i'm streaming rank not when i'm like i mean
i do have fun off stream it's because i don't take it
seriously i don't take it seriously anymore so like it's
only when i'm like uh uh it's only when i take it super
seriously that i don't have fun um but streaming rank
playing it and uh streaming for you guys i definitely
enjoyed a lot um i'm gonna head off now but thank you
everybody for watching Marvel Rivals, so we can compare
directly to Overwatch.
And they are releasing a couple of new characters for the
closed beta.
So it's going to be fun to see what that's about.
Hey guys, I'm going to call it here everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.